vous avez donc compris
que nous avions un petit problème et
donc je vous résume les sept cours
précédent qui connaît l'histoire de
faust dans cette salle vous n'êtes pas
très nombreux aussi n'ont relevé ni à la
main que je vois bon alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas faust c'est un homme qui
vend son âme au diable en échange d'un
instant de féliciter sur terre encore
notre sûr qu'il aura l'amour de la femme
dont il est épris donc les sept premiers
épisodes de secours c'est la partie
sympathique de l'histoire de faust c'est
à dire que on profite de ce qui se passe
sur terre
le huitième cour donc celui
d'aujourd'hui va s'attaquer à une fois
qu'on est en face du sujet comment
est-ce qu'on peut l'aborder
donc là je vais un tout petit peu pour
parler de mon métier quelque part qui n
importe quelle entité économique face
aux sujets que j'ai évoqué comment
est-ce qu'on s'empare du problème par
quel bout on le prend comment est-ce
qu'on laborde et je vais voilà donc ça
va être serré que les on va dire
quelques éléments de base sur le sujet
alors je vais un tout petit peu revenir
à cet homme-là dont je vous avais déjà
parlé parce que à partir du mans le dans
votre vie professionnelle là
on dira l'indicateur que vous allez
manipuler le plus souvent ça va
s'appeler d euros je vous le rappelle
vous allez pour un certain nombre
d'entre vous rentrez dans une entreprise
une entreprise est une entité économique
elle se définit même dans le code civil
comme une entité dont le but est de
faire du profit comme ça que c'est des
feelies un an code civil jeu d'autres
vont rentrer dans une administration
même dans une administration vous aurez
des gens qui vont s'occuper du budget
donc on va quand même s'occuper de
parler argent un petit peu même certains
d'entre vous qui vont rentrer dans une
association c'est un endroit on va vous
parler argent donc l'indicateur
transversale que vous allez le plus
manipulés dans votre vie professionnelle
c'est des sous je vous rappelle donc que
l'argent ne prend pas en compte par
construction les éléments qu'on a vu
pendant les sept premiers cours donc
pendant les sept premiers cours je vous
ai parlé de la dépendance de nos
activités productives à l'énergie je
vous ai parlé du changement climatique
rien de tout ça ne se trouve dans les
grandes heures économique que vous allez
manipulés qui s'appelle l'argent c'est
soit dit en passant bien pour cette
raison que on a aujourd'hui un conflit
d'objectif
quand on essaye de mariée à la fois
quelque chose qui marche bien du côté
argent est quelque chose qui marche bien
du côté entre guillemets je m'accommode
de limites sur l'énergie et le climat
c'est bien à cause de ça qu'on a un
problème c'est parce qu'on a des
conflits d'objectifs donc ce que dit
monsieur c'est ce que dit l'économie
classique c'est que cette chose là c'est
à dire la seule station spatiale que
nous connaissons et qui peut héberger
quelques milliards d'individus
c'est gratuit alors est ce que c'est
vraiment gratuit donc ça je vous le
rappelle il faut 14 milliards d'années
depuis le big bang pour faire ça deux
générations d'étoilés tu sais je vous
refais pas le topo donc la question
c'est est ce que c'est vraiment gratuit
alors pour comprendre à quel point tout
ça relève de la convention je vous
propose un petit exercice sur la maison
du saladier du salarié français le plus
irradiés de france l'ufal de salariés
les plus irradiés de france à vous
rappeler que thomas pesquet et salariés
le plusieurs années de france 180
millisieverts
pendant son voyage et en plus il veut y
retourner devant être ici donc vous avez
la station spatiale internationale qui
est une grosse boîte de conserve qui est
capable d'héberger six personnes à temps
plein d'accord ça vaut 100 milliards de
dollars
dit autrement le programme qui a permis
de construire la station spatiale
internationale vaut 100 milliards de
dollars alors 1 100 milliards de dollars
vous construisez dans l'espace un
réceptacle qui est capable d'héberger
six personnes c'est à dire que à 6
personnes ça fournit une protection
contre le vide intersidéral
il ya une pression d'une atmosphère une
protection contre le froid du vide
intersidéral parce que je rappelle qu'il
n'est pas très très chaud dans le vide
intersidéral il fait lors de quelques
degrés kelvin c'est pas terrible ça a
remarqué peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on
s'attaque aux padres
ça vaut fournit un cycle de l'eau
élémentaire donc vous buvez ce que vous
arrivez à récupérer dans vos urines mais
ça ne suffit pas il faut quand même de
temps en temps à acheminer un peu d'eau
par vaisseau cargo
et puis c'est à peu près tout si vous
avez aussi le droit d'appeler houston
pour dire que la planète c'est beau vu
d'en haut mais c'est à peu près tout ce
que vous avez le droit d'avoir pour 100
milliards de dollars et 6 personnes
d'accord y'a pas de quoi faire pousser
la moindre carottes
il n'y a pas la moindre vague pour aller
surfer sur l'océan
vous n'avez pas le moindre code
génétique de quelques espèces que ce
soit vous n'avez pas de poissons à
pêcher et vous n'avez pas enfin voilà
donc vous n'avez rien eu et pas de sable
pas de mine pas de minerais pas de
gisement de pétrole rien d'accord donc
pour 100 milliards de dollars pour 6
personnes c'est-à-dire 15 milliards de
dollars par personne
vous avez juste trois fonctions que la
nature nous fournit gratuitement sur
terre qui sont une pression à une
atmosphère au sol une température
raisonnablement clémente au sol et un
cycle de l'eau qui nous amène
naturellement l'eau au sol d'accord donc
ces trois trucs là vous allez dans
l'espace il faut 15 milliards de dollars
par personne pour les reconstituer
donc question à votre avis combien vaut
la planète
je vous dis au moins 15 milliards de
dollars par personne puisque la planète
nous assure au moins les trois fonctions
que je viens d'évoquer encore d'être
passé à respirable donc on va faire un
petit exercice comptable
un peu un peu rigolo donc la planète
vont au moins 15 milliards de dollars
par personne ce que on peut regarder
aujourd'hui quand on regarde le rythme
de consommation de la planète donc je
prends tous les stocks non renouvelables
qui sont situés sur la planète
les stocks de pétrole les stocks de
cuivre
les stocks de bauxite les stocks de
d'argent les stocks d'or les stocks etc
tous les minerais que je trouve dans la
terre et je regarde à quel rythme on les
exploite
est ce que je dis c'est actuellement les
stocks initiaux ont lésé on les diminue
on les exploite
on détruit le stock initial en
exploitant à hauteur de au moins un pour
mille par an est en fait si je prends le
pétrole c'est même plus que ça de même
quand je regarde le stock de poissons
qu'on avait dans l'atlantique nord en
1900 et que je le compare aux stocks de
poissons qu'on a dans la clique même
dans l'atlantique nord aujourd'hui je
constate qu'il a en gros pour les
espèces commerciales étaient divisées
par dix et c'est donc on explose vous
voyez une division par dix en un siècle
en fait c'est beaucoup plus de 1% par an
donc vous avez un rythme d'exploitation
alors moi je vais être sympa je vais me
contenter de 1 pour 1000 donc je vais
dire aujourd'hui ce capital naturel que
nous avons à notre disposition
je l'entâme le consomme donc je le
détruise hauteur d'environ 1 pour 1000
par an sinon plus donc un pour mille par
an ça veut dire que j'ai 15 millions de
charges puisque je consomme je détruis 1
pour mille d'un truc qui vaut au moins
15 milliards donc j'ai 15 millions de
charges par personne sur terre et par an
d'accord ont suivi le raisonnement un
jack j'ai un héritage initial qui vaut
15 milliards par personne et je détruis
1 pour mille de cet héritage tous les
angles donc cette destruction me coûte
15 millions par an en face de ça j'ai
une production économique comptait au
sens du pib qui elle voit à peu près 15
mille dollars par personne et par an
donc c'est dans le petit schéma que je
vous avais montré au cours du premier
cours c'est la var c'est le côté plus de
ce que je crée chaque année les voitures
des immeubles et c'est donc aujourd'hui
avec ce petit parallèle tout bête que je
viens de vous montrer vous vous rendez
compte que la vitesse à laquelle on
détruit
le capital naturel avec une convention
pour plus idiote qu'autre chose puisque
je dis ce capital naturel vaut au moins
ce que valent les trois premières
fonctions essentielles dans la station
spatiale internationale
je détruis le capital naturel mille fois
plus vite que je ne produis des objets
qui ont de la valeur pour les hommes
avec une convention pour plus idiote
qu'autre chose donc ce que je viens de
vous montrer là c'est que le fait de ne
pas avoir mis les ressources naturelles
dans les prix montrent que les prix ne
nous aide en rien mais j'insiste en rien
à gérer les problèmes que j'ai évoquée
pendant les sept premiers cours de cette
série corps donc le seul à aucun moment
en regardant les prix je n'aurais de moi
même la solution à décarbonés le monde
ça ne peut pas marcher simplement en
regardant les prix je vais encore le
dire autrement dans cette animation que
je vous avais passé au premier cours je
vous avais dit ce qu on compte
aujourd'hui c'est le flux annuel de
transformation je vous rappelle que le
pib est un flux annuel de transformation
c'est je prends des ressources et je les
transforme en produits manufacturés
alors qu' il faudrait si on voulait être
pertinent au regard des limites
physiques passer à une comptabilité de
stock
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois que je
détruis quelque chose à gauche j'inscris
- dans une colonne 1 en même temps que
quand je crée quelque chose à droite
s'inscrit plus dans une colonne le fait
que le pib soit une unité de flux est
pas une unité de stocks signifie
notamment que au moment où le pib
commence à faiblir
oui au moment où ce flux l'a d'ailleurs
trouvé ma souris au moment où ce fut là
commence à se tarir
parce que ici les stocks sont devenus
grossièrement insuffisant à ce moment je
suis beaucoup trop avancé dans la
dégradation du patrimoine de départ pour
espérer le remettre en état
c'est clair ou pas dit autrement quand
le flux annuel de transformation va
commencer à battre de l aile parce qu'on
aura trop entamé les stocks dont il se
nourrit et qui par ailleurs sont
gratuits à ce moment là on est trop
avancée dans la dégradation du système
pour espérer le remettre en état
c'est ce que dans cette excellente
ouvrage que je vous conseille de lire
deux des huit secondes qui a été écrit
en 1972 par une bande de physiciens du
hem haïti dont un certain dennis meadows
il avait dit que la croissance de le mée
doses avait expliqué que la poursuite de
la croissance perpétuelle c'est à dire
la poursuite de l'augmentation
perpétuelle de ce flux nous amènerait
selon toute vraisemblance dans un
système qui est à revoir dans une fin
qui s'appelle overshoot day collapse
c'est à dire que vous franchissez les
limites et après le truc s'effondre
parce que vous pouvez plus revenir en
arrière donc j'insiste beaucoup
là-dessus
l'indicateur monétaire est un indicateur
qui ne porte en lui même
aucune information sur les limites à
laquelle la distance pardon à laquelle
on se trouve de la limite physique ça ne
vous donne aucune indication pertinente
de ce point de vue ce qui veut dire que
si on veut traiter la limite il faut la
traiter en tant que tel avec sa
comptabilité à elle ne se recoupent pas
avec le avec la comptabilité monétaire
dit autrement je vais encore vous le
dire autrement si on regarde la
formation des prix donc on n'a que les
facteurs humains dedans est ce que je
vous dis moi c'est que en fait il faut
inclure dans la formation des prix
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la
ressource naturelle alors je peux
modifier la convention comptable jeu
pourrait modifier la convention
comptable ça serait une première option
donc la première option serait de dire
très bien je vais inclure ce qu'on
appelle une dotation aux amortissements
voc en comptabilité une dotation aux
amortissements c'est quelque chose que
vous faites quand vous consommez une
partie d'un stock corp votre stock
valait mille vous prenez 10 dedans il
reste plus que 990 et vous passez une
dotation aux amortissements qui est une
charge sur l'exercice de l'année où vous
avez diminuer le stock
on fait également sa avec les
immobilisations quand j'achète cette
table c'est ce qui s'appelle une
immobilisation c'est un élément de
capital et puis donc choc de la mettre
en comptabilité dans les actifs dans les
trucs qui nous valent quelque chose
d'une année sur l'autre
et chaque année je vais enlever un petit
morceau s'appelle une dotation aux
amortissements j'ai considéré que ce un
coup de moins en moins cher et le petit
morceau que j'enlève je le mets dans les
charges
donc là on pourrait passer une dotation
aux amortissements ce qui concerne la
consommation de ressources non
renouvelables et pour les risques qui
sont différées dans le temps
ce qui est très exactement le cas en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique
puisque vous vous rappelez qu'une bonne
partie des conséquences du changement
climatique sont différées dans le temps
si je prends un exemple très concret qui
est la température qu'il fait
aujourd'hui et plus encore la
température qui fera demain et après
demain
eh bien ce sont des conséquences de ce
que ma génération a fait jusqu en somme
en 2019 donc jusqu'en 1999
je caricature un peu 20 ans je les ai
pris de manière exacte donc là nous
sommes en train de voir les conséquences
de ce que ma génération a fait jusqu en
2000 ce que nous avons fait depuis 2000
n'a pas d' influence sur ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment c'est
simplement l'inertie du système qui nous
a amenés là où nous sommes
et donc les émissions que nous avons
faite entre 2000 et 2019 et 2020 près
par des canicules plus importante que
nous aurons de toute façon en 2040
même si demain matin on baisse les
émissions pas une très bonne nouvelle
mais c'est comme ça donc à partir du
moment où l'on sait je finis à partir du
moment où on sait qu'on va avoir des
conséquences futures qui sont les
résultats de nos actions passées en
comptabilité il ya quelque chose qui
correspond à ce type de situation qui
s'appelle une provision pour risques
alors le cas atypique c'est on vous fait
un procès il ya un risque que vous
perdiez et bien au moment où le procès
démarre vous inscrivez dans vos comptes
une provision pour risques qui est une
charge et qui correspond à l'espérance
mathématique de pertes que vous avez si
vous savez faire les calculs
vous savez pas parce qu'un petit côté
l'auto dans les procès mais la logique
c'est l'espérance mathématique de ce que
vous risquez de perdre et vous
connaissez dans vos comptes d'accor donc
en ce qui concerne le couple énergie
climat
pour le moment aucune première option
pourrait être de corriger les comptes
avec quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
la dotation aux amortissements est
quelque chose qui adorent de la
provision pour risques alors il y avait
deux questions une pluie
oui c'est pas que ce nom il n'y a pas
que ça parce que le jeu vous ai montré
au cours du premier du deuxième cours
sur les combustibles fossiles qu'il n'y
avait pas de lien entre pour le pétrole
entre la quantité disponible sur le
marché et son prix donc en fait quand
l'énergie ou une ressource se raréfie
c'est pas au travers des variations de
prix donc de la quantité de travail
humain puisque le prix c'est que j'ai eu
du travail et des rentes humaine que
vous allez voir nécessairement la
conséquence ça peut s'organiser
autrement oui
ah le prix ça c'est pas mon modèle c'est
ce que vous avez appris en cours
d'économie
le prix et ne reflètent ce que les
facteurs capital et travail capital
humain et travail humain donc en fait
vous n'avez c'est quand quand je vous
expliquais au premier cours qu'il ya
deux facteurs de production pris en
compte dans la représentation économique
qui sont capital humain et le travail
humain ça revient à dire que les prix ne
sont formés qu'avec du travail humain et
du capital humain on tient pas compte
des ressources naturelles dans la
formation des prix
c'est une autre façon d'exprimer avec
une belle équation parce que je sais
qu'ici on aime les équations
c'est une autre façon d'exprimer avec
une belle équation le fait que les
ressources sont gratuites saad
intervient pas dans la formation des
prix
l'existence de la ressource encore une
fois les gens qu'il faut payer pour y
accéder ça peut intervenir quand vous
payez quelqu'un si par exemple vous
allez chercher des nodules sais ce que
c'est que les nodules c'est des petites
boules contenant des métaux que vous
avez sur les planches et aussi indique
si vous allez chercher des nodules dans
l'espace intervint dans leurs espaces
océaniques international en dehors des
zones d'exclusivité économique
vous ne paierez pas l'accès à la
ressource puisqu'il ya personne pour
vous réclamer de l'argent tout ce que
vous paierez c'est travail humain pour y
accéder mais vous paierez pas si vous
allez chercher du pétrole dans un pays
il a par contre vous paierez d'accès à
la ressource parce qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui habite dans le pays qui vous dit
pour prendre mon pétrole qui va me payer
tu en voilà donc cessé et si la pluie
tombe tout seul
en ce moment elle sera bien inspiré de
le faire à ce moment vous payer ni le
travail ya ressources pays rien donc le
[Musique]
qu'est ce que veut dire donc le les prix
ce que je ce que je disais à l'instant
quand je vous disais si on surveille
simplement les indicateurs économiques
au moment où les indicateurs économiques
se dégradent de manière massive
on est trop près de la limite pour
pouvoir y fait quelques shows il faire
quelque chose ça revient à dire que les
prix ne vous donne pas les signaux
faibles
ça revient à dire que les prix ne vous
donne pas les signaux faibles
c'est un constat du passé ça vous donne
pas les signaux faibles
en fait si vous voulez mesurer les flux
en ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre ou les flux de carbone
et bien comme disait monsieur de la
palice la seule chose que vous ayez à
faire c'est de mesurer les flux de
carbone
donc il faut établir une comptabilité
qui est distincte de la comptabilité
monétaire qui n'est pas la comptabilité
monétaire et qui regarde directement les
flux physiques alors le bilan carbone
qui est en gros la manière aujourd'hui
dont on nomme la comptabilité carbone
il se situe ici c'est à dire que il
regarde avec 12 unités physique qui en
l'occurrence sont des unités de masse la
quantité de carbone qu'on extrait du sol
et qu'on va une fois la voix rauque si
décoller dans l'atmosphère est en fait
il fait ça pour tous les gaz à effet de
serre y compris le co2 le méthane et des
autres
de ce fait comme il se situe entre le
réservoir et l'atmosphère
il vous donne évidemment une visibilité
sur la contribution de nos activités à
l'enrichissement de l'atmosphère en co2
initialement c'est pour ça qu'il a été
fait mais il se trouve que par
construction et j'insiste par
construction la même métriques vous
donne également la distance à laquelle
vous êtes de l'épuisement des ressources
puisque si vous regardez les flux de
carbone
il doit bien le carbone doit bien avoir
été extrait de quelque part et ce
quelque part c'est un gisement de
combustible fossile donc le bilan
carbone
à ceci d'intéressant que la même
comptabilité physique peut vous
permettre
de vous attaquer à deux problèmes
distincts qui sont la question de la
disponibilité en combustibles fossiles
et la question du réchauffement
climatique corps peut avoir les deux
avec la même de la même maîtrise il ya
une question évidente qui se pose en ce
qui concerne la mesure des émissions
c'est pourquoi finalement il serait
légitime dans une comptabilité carbone
d'agréger des émissions qui prennent
place à paris à bordeaux et
éventuellement au milieu du gabon en ce
qui concerne la comptabilité monétaire
comme vous le savez probablement
l'argent est fongible donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a une
comptabilité qui vous compte des flux
monétaires quand vous achetez davis
un fois un fabricant japonais et bien
vous allez agrégé de l'argent qui a été
versé à des salariés japonais et de
l'argent qui va être versée à des
salariés français et on considère que
c'est quelque chose qui ne pose aucun
problème parce que la monnaie est
fongible est bien en ce qui concerne les
émissions
il faut également avoir une bonne raison
d'agréger des émissions qui prennent
place ici et des émissions qui prennent
place là alors je vais commencer par
prendre un exemple on sait pas légitime
de faire ça en ce qui concerne les
émissions de dioxyde de soufre le
dioxyde de soufre vous occasionner
essentiellement de la pollution locale
c'est à dire que ça va faire des plus
acide pas très loin de là où vous êtes
et ça va vous faire des aérosols
réfléchissant pas très loin de là où
vous êtes donc dire en ce qui concerne
les plus acides par exemple que mondiale
oxydes de soufre soit émis au milieu de
l'océan où qu'ils soient et mis au
milieu de l'europe c'est pareil c'est
pas légitime parce que si vous faites
une pluie acide au milieu de l'océan
une fois que la pluie s'est diluée dans
la masse océanique c1 strictement aucune
espèce d'importance alors que si vous
faites ça sur au dessus d'un continent
comme les conséquences vont se
concentrer
on va dire dans quelques centimètres où
quelques dizaines de centimètres de sol
vous avez évidemment pas du tout les
mêmes implications et par ailleurs les
végétaux sont plus sensibles à la chose
en ce qui concerne le co2
la raison pour laquelle il est légitime
de d'agréger des émissions ou qu'elles
prennent place c'est à cause des
caractéristiques physiques des gaz à
effet de serre physiques et chimiques je
vous ai indiqué que les gaz à effet de
serre étaient des espèces qui avait une
très grande longévité chimiques dans
l'atmosphère encore il reste longtemps
dans l'atmosphère des décennies ou des
siècles
or il se trouve que l'atmosphère à un
système de circulation à grande échelle
qui fait qu'elle est brassée sur à peu
près la totalité de la surface
planétaire en l'espace d'une année
dit autrement vous prenez une molécule
d'air qui se trouve quelque part dans
l'atmosphère et vous attendez à l'est
mais pas béton pas une mais deux années
et cette molécule d'air peut se
retrouver n'importe où donc vous avez un
brassage qui est fait dans l'atmosphère
par le biais des circulations
atmosphériques à large échelle dans
lesquelles vous avez notamment les
courants jet mais pas que à partir du
moment où vous mettez dans l'atmosphère
quelque chose qui va y rester des
siècles et que le brassage de
l'atmosphère se fait en un ou deux ans
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que le lieu
d'émission n'a strictement aucune espèce
d'importance et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous il est légitime
en ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de ne pas se soucier de
leur lieu de provenance de survenance
pour tenir compte de leur impact sur le
changement climatique
donc une entreprise ou qu'un pays
occasionne des émissions au nord de la
sibérie au milieu du brésil ou à
castelnaudary ça n'a strictement aucune
espèce d'importance en ce qui concerne
les conséquences
à suivre d'accord d'une manière générale
du coup ça veut dire que à partir du
moment où j'ai une chaîne de valeur donc
on va rester à côté de castelnaudary
nous sommes dans le sud ouest donc on va
s'intéresser au foie gras donc j'ai une
chaîne de valeur qui par des petits
canards et qui va jusqu'à l'assiette du
consommateur
eh bien je suis fondé si je veux
regarder l'impact de cette activité sur
le climat à prendre toutes les émissions
qui vont depuis la production du maïs
avec lesquels je nourris les canards
jusqu aux déjections des canards en
passant par les gens qui viennent
travailler pour nourrir puis zigouiller
des canards puis les gens qui fabriquent
le métal pour mettre le foie gras en
boîte puis la logistique aval pour
distribuer tout ça à droite et à gauche
et même éventuellement l'énergie de
cuisson pour faire cuire le foie gras
quand il écoulait donc ça une logique de
dire où que les émissions prennent place
de toute façon elles sont identiques en
ce qui concerne les faits sur le climat
et donc je peux les axes d'une part les
agrégés et d'autre part évidemment c'est
une des choses qu'on va voir derrière me
poser la question de savoir où est-ce
que c'est plus pertinent d'agir si je
veux commencer à les faire baisser
quand je mets des gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère
en fait j'ai un enchaînement on va dire
de cause et de conséquence donc je
commence par des émissions ses émissions
modifie la concentration atmosphérique
et du coup ça modifie le forçage
radiatif sacré du changement climatique
et tout ça va me créer les impacts et il
se trouve que pour mon plus grand
malheur ce qui a le plus de sens pour
moi assez de regarder les impacts dit
autrement ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
quand je rajoute des gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère c'est de savoir
si oui ou non je vais avoir tant de gens
qui vont mourir à cause de tels calculs
d'accord c'est l'impact qui m'intéresse
vraiment et est ce que oui ou non je
vais perdre 30 % de la récolte sur les
pommes de terre ça ça m'intéresse
alors que malheureusement tout ce que je
sais mesuré quand je fais des émissions
c'est les émissions donc il ya une
difficulté intrinsèque dans cette
affaire-là qui est que ce qu'on cherche
à éviter c'est les impacts mais que ce
qu'on sait mesurer ses des émissions
alors ça a l'air idiot
dit comme ça mais sauf que comme vous
avez l'atmosphère entre les deux est
donc un grand pot commun entre les deux
on est donc dans un système dans lequel
personne ne va hériter des impacts de
ses propres émissions corps donc ce que
les ce que les gens peuvent mesurer et
ceux dont vous
hériter c'est de la mesure de vos
propres les émissions mais il se trouve
que la mesure de vos propres émissions
ça n'est pas l'impact de vos propres
émissions
parce qu'en fait l'impact c'est l'impact
de l'ensemble des émissions dit
autrement la canicule que vous aurez en
france en 2050 dépens un tout petit peu
de ce que les français vont faire sur
leurs propres émissions et dépend
essentiellement de ce que les chinois
les indiens les indonésiens les
philippins les vietnamiens les
camerounais les brésiliens et les
canadiens évidemment les américains vont
faire sur leurs émissions donc le
l'impact c'est ce qui nous intéresse
vraiment pas ce que c'est de savoir si
on va mourir au pas mourir mais ce qu'on
sait mesurer c'est pas ça c'est les
émissions alors il se trouve que vous
avez deux unités qui vont être
importantes et que je vais évoquer enfin
de grandeur exactement que je vais
évoquer juste après enfin une que je
vais évoquer l'autre très peu en ce qui
concerne le forçage radiatif l'unité
qu'on va utiliser s'appelle le global
warming potential où le pouvoir de
réchauffement global en français prg et
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique
il ya une autre unité mais dont je vous
parle très peu parce qu'on s'en sert
quasiment jamais qui est le global
température potential qui est pas
exactement la même alors le global
warming potential son principe et sa
philosophie c'est de mesurer la quantité
totale d'énergie renvoyé vers la surface
qui va faire suite à l'envoi dans
l'atmosphère d'une unité de gaz à effet
de serre
donc j'en vois une unité de gaz à effet
de serre dans l'atmosphère du coup j'ai
augmenté l'effet de serre du coup j'ai
augmenté le flux radiatif renvoyé vers
le sol et la question c'est quel est le
lien entre le supplément de gaz à effet
de serre que j'ai rajouté dans
l'atmosphère et le supplément d'énergie
que je vais récupérer au sol et comme
c'est un forçage radiatif donc une
puissance ce supplément d'énergie
je ne peux le calculé que si je me donne
un horizon de temps donc le forçage
radiatif pas dans le pouvoir de
réchauffement global
il est défini comme le forçage radiatif
du gaz qui m'intéresse cumulé sur un
horizon de temps donné et plutôt que de
le mesurer en valeur absolue
on a décidé que ça simplifierait le
boulot des ingénieurs que vous êtes de
le mesurer en relatifs et donc je le
ramène à exactement la même chose en ce
qui concerne le co2 donc le pouvoir de
réchauffement global d'un gaz à effet de
serre en gros c'est un multiple du
pouvoir de réchauffement global du co2
c'est ça le sait ça le pardon c'est un
multiple du forçage radiatif cumulé du
co2 et ça correspond à la question qui
est combien de fois plus par rapport au
co2 ou combien de fois moins par rapport
au co2 ça va me renvoyer de l'énergie
vers la surface à un horizon de temps
donné le prg du co2 quel que soit
l'horizon de temps et bien évidemment un
par définition donc c'est une unité
relative c'est une unité normalisée
alors ici vous avez un tableau extrait
du dernier rapport du giec qui vous
donne les valeurs pour un certain nombre
de gaz et vous voyez que en gros tous
les gaz à effet de serre ont un prg qui
est supérieur à 1
enfin à part le co2 ils ont tous un prg
qui est supérieur à vous avez ici les
horizons de temps 20 et sentant alors à
20 et à sang tant le prg pas le même
parce que comme une unité de gaz à effet
de serre que vous rajouter dans le post
faire à l'instant zéro ne secure pas à
la même vitesse en fonction des gaz et
par ailleurs n'a pas le même pouvoir
absorbant dans l'infrarouge en fonction
du gaz par unité de masse et bien le le
fait que les comment dire que les durées
de vie dans l'atmosphère ne soient pas
les mêmes font qu'en fonction de
l'horizon de temps le rapport entre le
gaz en question et le co2 change
dit autrement si vous avez un gaz dans
la durée de vie est plus courte que
celle du co2 le prg diminue quand
l'horizon de temps s'allonge
si vous avez à gaz qui est plus long en
durée de vie que le co2 dans
l'atmosphère typiquement les gaz fluorés
et qu'on utilise dans les chaînes de
froid
à ce moment le prg augmente avec
l'horizon temporel d'accord alors vous
allez me dire c'est passionnant tout ça
mais pourquoi est-ce que ça on sent
kittin on peut on prend un siècle et
puis on ne parle plus alors on sent
qu'ils quittent parce que quand il faut
passer à l'action si votre patron vous
dit bon je veux faire baisser les
émissions de 3%
et puis j'ai le choix entre baisser un
peu les fluides d'enfin à utiliser un
peu moins de fuites dans la climat ou
bien utiliser un peu moins de camions
dans la logistique ou bien ceux ci ou
bien cela si vous ne savez pas comparer
les gaz vous n'êtes pas capables de
passer à l'action
parce que vous n'êtes pas capables de
comparer les effets de vos actions et
donc l'horizon temporel à quelque chose
d'important
un exemple parmi d'autres si vous passez
l'horizon temporel de 100 ans à 20 ans
la question du cheptel bovin devient une
question absolument crucial alors
qu'avec le pouvoir de réchauffement
global à 100 ans c'est beaucoup moins
visible dans le panorama des émissions
c'est déjà pas mal visible mais ça l'est
beaucoup moins
voilà un exemple donc si vous dites que
le prg on le prend à 20 ans vous aurez
plus envie d'enquiquiner les éleveurs
que si vous le prenez un siècle
vous voyez ça une conséquence très très
directe pour l'action derrière cette
affaire-là
c'est le truc dont je vous ai pas parlé
c'est le global température potential en
fait c l'élévation temps cardon
e
ccfb il ya le global à part danser
carbone feedback excusez moi c'est oui
des wild cards feedback je sais que ça
le carbone feedback je vous en ai parlé
au moment du cours sur les conséquences
du réchauffement climatique
c'est en tenant compte du réchauffement
sur le déstockage des stocks de carbone
ou pas donc c'est selon votre modèle est
couplé sur le cycle du carbone et
transfère en compte ou pas et donc ça
vous augmente toujours un peu le le
pouvoir de réchauffement global
une fois qu'on est capable de comparer
les gaz
on est donc capable de faire un
inventaire tougas confondues quand on
peut prendre en compte à la fois le
méthane le co2 un chien ce qui vient des
lâches il ya des vaches qui vient
derrière et si bien des voitures le le
premier inventaire de gaz à effet de
serre qui a été mis en oeuvre à large
échelle
c'est les inventaires d'émissions
territoriaux dans le cadre de la
convention qui barrent vous savez que
dans le cadre de la convention climat
tous les pays du monde en 1992 donc
avant votre naissance se réunissent à
rioz et disent que on va s'occuper de
faire quelque chose de sérieux pour le
climat résultat c'est pas encore très
probants
donc les pays ratifient notamment donc
une convention qui dit qu' on va se
donner un objectif de maintenir le
changement climatique anthropique à des
niveaux qui ne présente pas de danger
pour l'homme c'est très exactement comme
ça que c'était rédigé nous allons
limiter le changement climatique à des
niveaux qui ne présente pas de danger
pour l'homme c'était ça l'objectif de la
convention
cadre qui a été adoptée à rio en 1992
dans le cadre de cette convention
il a été décidé que chaque pays
mesurerait ses émissions alors il se
trouve que depuis le traité de west
valley qui a décidé que les états enfin
qui a dit que les états étaient
souverain dit autrement que ce qui se
passait à l'intérieur des frontières
s'étaient eux qui décident à et personne
d'autre donc la seule exception étant
quand on s'en va et les uns les autres
mais à part ça on décida chez soi comme
on veut ça revient à dire que chaque
état en ce qui concerne les émissions ne
peut stipuler que pour lui-même d'
accord donc il ne peut s'engager que
pour ses propres aux émissions parce que
les émissions qu'on lui ailleurs absent
dans un autre état et donc c'est un
autre et à s'en occuper et donc on a
fait on a mis en place un système
d'inventaire domestique donc
l'inventaire domestique c'est je compte
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui ont lieu chez moi ses émissions dont
par construction se limite aux sources
présentes sur le territoire
donc si vous avez une aciérie sur le
territoire les émissions de co2 de la
syrie sont dans l'inventaire si vous
importez de l'acier en provenance d'un
pays tiers
les émissions de fabrication de l'acier
sont pas dans votre inventaire c'est la
grosse différence entre ce qu'on appelle
un inventaire national et une vision
empreinte carbone ou là on regarde tout
ce qui est la contrepartie de ce que
vous consommez que ça a été fabriquée
chez vous ou pas c'est bien évidemment
quelque chose qui intègre tous les gaz à
effet de serre connu alors il y en a 1
supplémentaire maintenant qui est le n
un effroi si ma mémoire est bonne enfin
bon il est totalement insignifiant dans
les inventaires et au début de la
convention climat il ya également eu un
mécanisme je pars on est dans des
tailles qui était un mécanisme par
lequel on pouvait déduire de son
inventeur le bien entre guillemets qu'on
faisait dans un autre pays c'est ce
qu'on appelait les mécanismes de
développement propre ou le job
diplômante ascione dans le cadre du
protocole de kyoto mais en gros un
inventaire national
aujourd'hui c'est donc l'inventaire de
l'ensemble des sources qui prennent
place sur le territoire
et c'est également l'inventeur du puy
forestier territoriale donc en france il
ya un organisme qui est chargé d'établir
cet inventaire qui s'appelle le citepa
séité au pea qui vient soit dit en
passant de publier les émissions de la
gaze de gaz à effet de serre de la
france pour 2018 bon jusqu'en 2018
sachant que les émissions de co2 elles
commencent à être mesurées depuis 1960
et pour les autres gaz depuis 1990 et le
citepa vous donne les émissions par
grands secteurs des missions donc ils
vous donnent les émissions des bâtiments
les transports les industries de
l'énergie etc
c'est de cet organisme que viennent les
émissions que je vous ai montré pendant
le cours sur le changement climatique en
vous donnant la trajectoire des missions
de la france donc tous les pays ont un
organisme de cette nature il soit dit en
passant
vous avez également aujourd'hui
maintenant un processus de contrôle
qualité par lequel les les organismes
qui font l'inventaire dans un pays soit
en général visités par leurs homologues
d'un autre pays étrangers pour qu'ils
s'échangent les bonnes pratiques que les
regarde comment ils ont fait des dix
tient là tu as peut-être fait une bêtise
désormais les acteurs économiques
français ont également une obligation de
faire ce genre de choses alors
historiquement la première loi qui a
obligé les entreprises françaises à
mesurer leurs émissions
c'était la loi grenelle 2 qui avait été
votée en 2010 alors cette loi grenelle 2
n'était pas extrêmement contraignantes
parce que elle disait en gros que on ne
s'occupait que des émissions directes
donc en fait c'était bien dans le
principe simplement c'était extrêmement
limitant en ce qui concernait le
périmètre couvert
parce que vous êtes par exemple un
magasin carrefour et bien les seules
émissions qu'on vous demande est
d'inventorier au titre de cette loi
c'est les émissions de votre chaudière
or les émissions des véhicules pour que
les clients viennent chez vous on compte
pas les émissions des camions qui vous
livre les produits on compte pas les
émissions pour fabriquer les produits on
compte pas et si vous vendez des
produits qu'ils consomment de l'énergie
donc des aspirateurs ou des barbecues et
bien on compte pas donc en gros
l'essentiel des émissions dont dépend
votre activité parce que si vous n'avez
plus le droit d'utiliser un barbecue
acheté chez carrefour vous n'allez pas
l'acheter chez carrefour et si vous
n'avez plus le droit de brancher une
perceuse acheté chez leroy merlin vous
n'allez pas l'acheter chez leroy merlin
dont par ailleurs si vous n'avez plus
droit de prendre votre voiture pour
aller faire des courses ça change aussi
un tout petit peu la structure du
commerce de ces gens là donc en gros
cette loi grenelle 2 elle demandait
vraiment à ce qu'on se concentre sur un
truc qui était totalement ici l'omesc
par contre maintenant il ya une deuxième
loi qui est passé en 2015
et qui dit qu' il faut prendre en compte
les émissions bonjour vous lirez sert à
tête reposée qu'il faut prendre en
compte les émissions qui sont la
contrepartie de l'activité de façon
beaucoup plus large donc en gros c'est
les postes significatives d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et en fait c'est de
ça dont je vous parlais dans les
quelques cas pratiques qu'on va voir
ensuite donc les postes significatives
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre j'en
reviens à mon magasin carrefour
typiquement si je trouve pas les camions
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui manque
si je trouve pas les voitures des
clients qui viennent dans les grandes
surfaces c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
qui manque si je trouve pas les
émissions de fabrication des produits
qu'il s'agisse des biftecks ou qu'il
s'agisse des perceuses ou tout ce que
vous des poupées barbie et bien il ya
quelque chose qui manque et on peut même
inclure dans cette logique les émissions
de cuisson des surgelés de conservation
des surgelés pour le plus précisant
frigo avant d offrir les manger donc
vous avez tous acquis
normalement doit être pris en compte
dans l'inventaire oui c'est pas un
problème je vous en parlais juste après
oui ça ne pose aucun problème de compter
quelque chose de fois dans le monde
économique ont fait ça en permanence
quand ma société envoie une facture à un
client la facture elle est comptabilisée
chez moi et elle est comptabilisée chez
les clients quand vous avez au sein d'un
même groupe
deux entités qui s'envoient une facture
l'une à l'autre eh bien ça apparaît dans
les comptes de chacune des entités
évidemment quand vous allez faire la
comptabilité de l'ensemble de l'entité
vous avez ce qu'on appelle des
retraitements à faire et c'est ça qui
vous permet de sortir des comptes qu'on
appelle consolidé dans les comptes
consolidés sont des comptes dans
lesquels vous avez enlevé tout ce qui
est en double on est en ce qui concerne
la comptabilité carbone
quand vous regardez une entité prise
isolément le fait qu'ils aient un double
compte avec ce qui se passe dans une
autre entité c'est pas très grave parce
que de toute façon votre problème à vous
c'est de regarder tout ce dont vous
dépendez donc au motif que ce dont vous
dépendez se passe chez le voisin
il faut pas le retirer de votre champ de
vision sinon vous allez faire une erreur
d'appréciation sur la situation dans
laquelle vous êtes il ya un deuxième wii
oui
alors les eaux internationales ne sont
pas considérés comme un puits forestier
pour l'excellente raison que la forêt
qui pousse et la surface de l'océan et
en quantité assez réduite donc on ne
compte pas et en fait les émissions qui
sont absorbés par l'océan
elles ne sont la propriété de personne
donc en fait elles n'apparaissent dans
aucun inventaire
j'insiste un inventaire des missions
c'est pas un inventaire de variation de
la concentration et c'est pas un
inventaire des impacts c'est vraiment un
inventaire des missions dont vous
regardez ce qu'on aimait et vous
déduisez de ce qu'on aimait sous
certaines conditions
ce que votre forêt capte à condition
qu'elles captent quelque chose donc dans
les pays dans lesquels vous êtes en
déforestation non seulement y à pas
depuis forestier il ya une source
forestière par exemple dans un pays
comme l'indonésie
je sais pas si c'est encore vrai
aujourd'hui mais il ya encore pas si
longtemps que ça et bien avant bien
après que j'ai commencé mes cours ici
la diminution de la surface forestière
était le premier poste des missions du
pays vers le fait qu'on supprime un
stock qui derrière part dans
l'atmosphère sous forme de démission de
combustion c'était de très loin le
premier poste d'inventaires d'émissions
du pays si vous êtes dans un pays comme
le brésil c'est pareil la forêt n'est
pas appuyé la forêt est une source
d'émissions parce que vous êtes en face
de déforestation par contre si vous êtes
dans un pays comme la france où
globalement la surpêche de la superficie
forestière a tendance à croître un peu
et bien à ce moment sous réserve qu'on
ne compte pas en forêt des trucs où il y
a pas d'arbres et ça peut arriver
par exemple s'il ya des incendies par
exemple à ce que les arbres meurent à
cause des ravageurs par exemple parce
qu'on les ya quelques années de suite on
les coupe rapidement alors même que
cadastre allemand ça reste des forêts
mais globalement la forêt française est
en croissance et donc on a un puits
forestier donc ça dépend de ce que le
stock foresti est en croissance ou
décroissance mais s'il est en croissance
c'est un puits dans l'inventaire s'il
est en décroissance votre stock
forestier à ce moment c'est une source
dans l'inventaire dans les deux cas de
figure c'est une source qui est
compliqué à apprécier parce que j'en
reviens à ce que j'ai dit au moment des
énergies renouvelables le
les sources fossiles vont en regardant
une comptabilité commerciale
donc je vous assure que le pompiste qui
vous vend votre essence il est intéressé
à ce que consent compteur soit pas faux
et que vous serviez pas le double de ce
qu'il pense qu'il vous a vendu bon il
regarde très précisément ce qui se passe
est donc une fois que je sais très
précisément la quantité d'essence qui
rentrait dans votre voiture je sais très
précisément la quantité de co2 qu'un
sort en ce qui concerne le bois c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'aller demander
à chaque arbre pas stocker combien de
carbone cette année toi donc c'est
nécessairement des calculs qui sont
grossiers approximatif avec des fortes
incertitudes
bon ça c'est juste pour vous rappeler
que les deux parts dans le tibre je
reviens un truc sur l'article 173
alors il ya un autre truc qui concerne
aujourd'hui pas trop vous parce que
normalement pas tout ce que je vous ai
raconté il y avait quand même pas 1
milliards qui devraient aller bosser
dans la finance pour devenir trader
s'est jamais après tout mais par contre
il y en a quand même peut-être
quelques-uns qui ont quand même et dans
le secteur financier
il ya une obligation supplémentaire qui
a été rajoutée au titre de cette même
loi 2015 sur la transition énergétique
qui dit que tous les acteurs du monde
financier doivent publier un rapport
pour dire comment est ce qu'ils prennent
en compte à la fois le l'empreinte
carbone on va dire de leur portefeuille
parce que quand vous êtes un
investisseur financier en général et du
reste parce que vous gérer l'épargné ou
la trésorerie quelqu'un c'est ça le
l'essentiel des investisseurs donc si
vous parents de l'assurance vie eh bien
ils ont donné à une compagnie
d'assurance vie leur argent et d'autres
compagnies d'assurance vie va acheter
des obligations et les actions sert de
la dette et des actions d'un certain
nombre d'états pour la dette et d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises ces états
et ses entreprises émettent des gaz à
effet de serre il en maîtres sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur et
donc l'article 173 dit vous qui êtes
dans le monde financier
vous allez vous intéresser à ce truc là
et vous allez commencer à me raconter
des choses sur la façon dont vous prenez
en compte l'empreinte carbone du
portefeuille dans deux de vos
investissements et par ailleurs
j'aimerais bien que vous me racontiez
également des chaussures l'impact du
changement climatique sur les activités
dans lesquelles vous avez investi
donc si vous avez investi chez un
producteur de pommes de terre
j'aimerais que vous preniez le temps de
regarder si le changement climatique va
pas lui faire faire de très mauvaise
affaire
alors pour vous donner un exemple qui
est un peu avoir plus à large échelle
l'allemagne a connu une petite récession
fin 2018 il se trouve que à l'été 2010 8
l'est de la france et donc le sud de
l'allemagne a connu une sécheresse très
intenses se rappelle peut-être quelques
souvenirs à quelqu'un s'il ya des gens
ici qui sont originaires du doubs du
jura
on a des gens qui sont originaires du
doubs du jura et encore moins des
bretons bon bah c'est pas la voilà en
fait ma confiance
enfin sur parole donc dans ce coin là il
a fait très sec et le débit du rhin a
considérablement baissé et le rhin
a cessé d'être navigables pour les
transports de marchandises un peu lourd
du coup ça a empêché quelques centrales
électriques au charbon d'être
approvisionné et ça a supprimé le
transport de marchandises pour une
partie des activités industrielles en
allemagne
eh bien ça a probablement joué un rôle
dans la récession qui a eu en allemagne
au quatrième trimestre 2010 8 parce que
le sud de l'allemagne qui jouxte la
france est une partie extrêmement
industrialisés dans laquelle vous avez
de grosses concentrations notamment dans
le faisait pas très loin de l'industrie
automobile et voilà donc ça c'est un
exemple d'impact du changement
climatique sur les activités économiques
vous en avez évidemment plein d'autres
que je pourrais prendre en exemple quand
vous avez la température là avec les
températures qui va faire pendant les
quelques jours qui viennent vous avez
des sols qui vont s'assécher de manière
forte
ça va vous faire de la rétractation des
argiles sa fissure et des bâtiments ça a
été le plus vrai le premier dommages
assurés en 2003 voilà donc vous avez un
certain nombre de conséquences donc en
fait la loi de 2015 dit aux gens qui ont
investi de l'argent quelque part
intéressez-vous à cette affaire là pour
le moment c'est des obligations très
très soft c'est ce que les anglo-saxons
appellent complet you explain dit
autrement vous pouvez soit complet
c'est-à-dire faire ce qu'on vous demande
de faire soit explained c'est à dire
expliquer pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait
donc c'est un truc évidemment très très
soft si on vous demande de faire d'aller
en contrôle et que vous y allez pas et
vous dit que j'avais une bonne raison
j'avais des qui grattent très bien pas
de problème est évident qu'un certain
nombre d'entre vous mais vous passerez
quand même problème était bien qu'un
certain nombre d'entre vous préférons
les faire la fête donc c'est exactement
ce que font les financiers ils font un
peu la fête donc pour le moment ils sont
pas très sérieux sur cette obligation
est un certain nombre de gens comme moi
milite pour qu'il le soit un peu plus
bon ça je vais passer parce que ça n'a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt plus beaucoup
d'intérêt aujourd'hui au moment où
l'article 173 de la loi est passée la
france cocorico était le seul pays au
monde qui demandait aux entreprises de
reporter les émissions sur l'ensemble
des processus amont et aval dont elles
dépendent donc je reprends l'exemple de
la grande surface
à cette époque là les pays vous avez là
demandez simplement qu'on fasse un
'reporting' des émissions directes
c'est ça qu'on appelle le ce copain est
ce qu'on appelle le scope de en fait
c'est les émissions indirectes du à
l'approvisionnement énergétique
dit autrement c'est les émissions des
centrales électriques de l'électricité
que vous achetez donc l'essentiel des
pays du monde qui avait mis une
obligation de déclaration des émissions
aux entreprises
demandez à ces entreprises de simplement
communiquer sur les émissions liées à
leur propre consommation énergétique
alors vous vous appelez bnp paribas les
émissions de la propre consommation
énergétique de bnp paribas
c'est l'électricité que vous achetez le
gars à ce que vous achetez le fioul que
vous achetez s'il ya quelques agences
bancaires chauffées au fioul et les
voitures de fonction qui sont possédés
par l'entreprise point ce que vous
pensez que c'est extrêmement
représentatif des émissions de bnp
paribas ont fait exactement des
émissions dont dépend l'aide des paris
va pas vraiment je reprends l'exemple de
carrefour si vous avez juste la
chaudière du magasin carrefour s'est pas
non plus vraiment très représentatif
donc le et si je prends l'école des
mines
c'est juste la chaudière de l'école des
mines vous n'avez pas là dedans ni les
produits alimentaires servi au
restaurant ni les voyages en avion vous
allez faire pour partir en stage ni le
matériel qui est acheté pour les
laboratoires ni tour et tout ça
disparaît donc c'est quelque chose qui
est évidemment très très partiel et si
vous demandez aux gens de ne mesurer
qu'une petite partie du problème
à ce moment vous avez les filles
lampadaires que vous connaissez tous un
pur est ce que tu cherches des clés sous
le lampadaire à clapet de la lumière
c'est évident que si vous dites aux
entreprises tu ne va regarder que les
émissions qui ont lieu chez toi ensuite
sur quoi est ce qu'elles vont agir va
juste sur les élections qui ont lieu
chez elles seulement ayant donc
carrefour on va vous expliquer que c'est
vachement bien parce qu'ils ont réduit
ils ont augmenté l'efficacité
énergétique de leur chaudière de 10%
donc je reviens sur quelque chose qui
est absolument essentiel c'est que quand
vous faites un inventaire des missions
la première raison de le faire c'est pas
pour vous sentir coupable c'est pour
comprendre de quel processus dépend
votre activité
c'est ça la première raison de faire un
inventaire des missions
ce qui veut dire que donc je voulais
déjà 10 25 fois dans le magasin d'accord
prenons maintenant l'exemple d'un
distributeur d'eau donc pour ne pas les
nommer ou veolia ou suez ou leur copain
est bien bien évidemment un distributeur
d'eau au centre huillo pour faire
circuler l'eau ça marche pas bien donc
dans l'inventaire des missions d'un
distributeur d'eau vous devez
logiquement trouver les émissions de
fabrication des tuyaux ils sont
renouvelés
donc le plasturgiste qui a fait les
tuyaux en pvc ou pont-à-mousson café les
tuyaux en fonte ou qui a fait les
regards en fonte et bien vous allez
devoir trouver les émissions de ces gens
là dans l'inventaire des missions de mon
distributeur d'eau soit dit en passant
dans l'inventaire de mon distributeur
d'eau il ya un autre truc que vous
devriez trouver aussi qui est encore
plus important que ça c'est tout
simplement le fait que l'essentiel de
l'eau distribuée est chauffée donc si je
n'ai plus le droit de chauffer l'eau que
j'achète
alors si je vous interdis à partir de
maintenant de chauffer l'eau chez vous
ces douches froides ou rien vous allez
probablement qu'on se met un peu moins
d'eau domestiquement parce que si ces
douches froides ou rien c'est pas
complètement sûr que vous garderez le
même rythme de douche que celui que vous
avez aujourd'hui voilà j'étais un peu
plus d'eau pour la machine à laver mais
comme ça sera interdite chauffer l'eau
pour la machine à laver aussi vous ferez
la lessive à l'eau froide compliqué si
maintenant je prends à coiffeur et bien
le coiffeur hérite pour partie du bilan
carbone de l'oréal d'accord puisque chez
le coiffeur vous allez trouver tout un
tas de produits qui sont vendus par
l'oréal et ses et consorts des
shampoings des lacs des tout un tas de
machins pour teindre les cheveux dans
toute la couleur sympathique etc
si je regarde maintenant à un
constructeur d'immeubles et bien le
constructeur d'immeubles il a
logiquement dans ses émissions le fait
qu'on puisse servir de l'immeuble une
fois vendus c'est pareil si tout ce que
je construis c'est des immeubles dans
lesquels n'y a pas de confort thermique
probablement que je vais les vendre un
peu moins facilement que des immeubles
dans lesquels il est possible d'avoir
chaud l'hiver est froid l'été
si je vends un immeuble qui n'est jamais
accessible
par aucun moyen de transport par exemple
au milieu de l'océan eh bien il va
valoir un peu moins cher pour quelqu'un
qui a besoin d'aller travailler à paris
tous les jours que quelque chose qui est
mieux situé donc si je ne tiens pas
compte des émissions de fonctionnement
de l'immeuble à la fois pour les
déplacements et pour le confort
thermique et bien il ya quelque chose
qui me manque
dans l'inventaire des missions des
constructeurs d'immeubles c'est
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne des
constructeurs de voitures si je regarde
les émissions directes d'un constructeur
de voitures ça ne m'apprend strictement
rien sur la dépendance du constructeur
de voitures aux émissions je vous le dis
autrement dans un monde dans lequel je
contracte les émissions de façon forte
donc je dis très bien on va faire le
monde à 2 degrés c'est à dire le monde
dans lequel on divise des émissions par
voulait dit la dernière fois par trois
d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon âge c'est
simple et bien dans ce monde là ce qui
va gêner mon constructeur de voitures
c'est avant tout les émissions des
voitures une fois en fonctionnement
beaucoup plus que les émissions de sa
propre show guerre c'est vraiment ça qui
va s'gêner donc dans un inventaire des
missions qui est fait pour comprendre le
lien de dépendance et du coup je qu'on
devient dans un monde dans lequel les
émissions baisse de gré ou de force
il est essentiel d'avoir les émissions
de l'ensemble d'un de la chaîne de
valeur et pour reprendre l'exemple de
bnp paribas
il est évident que dans les émissions de
bnp paribas ce qui va compter le plus
c'est pas du tout ses émissions directes
cc d'émissions indirectes c'est-à-dire
le fait que les activités dans
lesquelles on a investi aux activités
auxquelles on a prêté puisse fonctionner
parce que si tout le monde fait faillite
un tout petit sujet quand vous êtes une
banque est par ailleurs un certain
nombre d'autres émissions et notamment
les émissions de fonctionnement de tout
ce qui est informatique j'ai pas prévu
d'en parler pendant le court mais je
fais une petite parenthèse la modeste
association que j'ai l'honneur de
présider qui s'appelle de chiffres
project a sorti il ya trois quatre mois
cinq mois j'ai plus un rapport sur
l'empreinte carbone du numérique que je
vous invite à aller consulter
donc c'est sur un site internet ce qui
s'appelle de chiffres project.eu faciles
à trouver et vous verrez il ya des
indications assez intéressante sur ce
truc là je vous donne très rapidement la
conclusion c'est que la digitalisation
est un facteur d'accroissement des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et pas
du tout d'économies voilà c est ennuyeux
quand on a découvert ça on était un peu
en kittin et donc on peut faire comme le
toute activité économique est une
activité de transformation et que toute
transformation va avec de l'énergie etc
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de l'énergie et
fossiles vous pouvez faire le bilan
carbone de toute activité économique
encore il y aura toujours du carbone
donc en fait le carbone c'est une
monnaie exactement comme j'avais dit
tout à l'heure que les oraux ou les
dollars
c'est une monnaie le carbone c'est une
modèle c'est exactement pareil
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez utiliser pour agréger tous
les processus qui compte dans une
transformation productive et par
ailleurs c'est quelque chose que vous
pouvez
qu'en dire mettre sur un pied d'égalité
quel que soit l'endroit où vous en êtes
servis voilà donc quelques quelques
autres entités en fait n'importe
laquelle je peux faire son sens en
disant qu apple dans un lot d'une
empreinte carbone va bien en carbone
d'entreprise vous avez donc tout ce qui
rentrent en ligne de compte la seule
chose que vous n'allez pas prendre en
compte c'est les émissions directes de
vapeur d'eau donc si vous avez des
centrales électriques refroidi en
rivière vous ne tiendrait pas compte de
la vapeur d'eau est mise alors que l'eau
est un gaz arts de bordeaux est un gaz à
effet de serre et vous le ferez ça
pourquoi vous ferez ça parce que maîtres
de la vapeur d'eau ne modifie pas de
façon significative la concentration en
vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère
la concentration en vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère elle est pilotée par le
fait que vous ayez deux tiers d'océan
sur terre et la température de
l'atmosphère c'est ça qui pilote la
concentration à vapeur d'eau c'est pas
nos émissions qui change quelque chose
donc ça veut dire que les gaz dont on va
tenir compte
c'est juste ceux pour lesquels l'homme
modifie de façon distinctive la
concentration atmosphérique donc la
vapeur d'eau ne tenais pas à n'est pas
prise en compte
le co2 bien évidemment est pris en
compte ainsi que tous les gars s'ils ont
des émissions directes
par contre les gaz qui n'ont pas
d'émissions directes ne sont pas non
plus pris en compte par exemple l'ozone
troposphérique donc celui qui apparaît
près du sol et qui soit dit en passant à
mon avis avec les conditions qu'on a en
ce moment là gentiment augmenté et bien
ça c'est pas pris en compte alors que
c'est un gaz à effet de serre pourquoi
parce que vous n'avez pas de lien direct
entre le surplus atmosphérique et le
comportement d'un individu donné en ce
qui concerne les gaz qui se retrouvent
dans l'atmosphère sous la forme sous
laquelle ils ont été émis
vous avez un lien direct entre le
comportement d'un individu donné et le
surplus atmosphérique six mois
aujourd'hui
j'émets un kilo gaz à effet de serre je
sais faire le lien avec le supplément de
concentration que y'a juste après par
contre l'ozone ne s'aimait pas en tant
que tel et si tout de suite là
maintenant j'aimais des oxydes d azote
je ne sais pas dire combien d'ozone ça
fera en plus dans l'atmosphère parce que
ça dépend de ce que les autres vont
faire des conditions climatiques et de
est ce que au même moment on a émis des
composés organiques volatils ou pas
et donc comme je le disais ce qu'il va
faire beau et si ya pas faire bon donc
je n'ai pas de lien direct entre la
quantité d'ozone que vous avez dans
l'atmosphère et le comportement d'un
individu pris isolément
et ça ça explique pourquoi aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de metric on ne prend pas
en compte
l'ozone dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans tous les inventaires
qu'on fait aujourd'hui l'unité de compte
est toujours le prg à un siècle encore
c'est ça l'unité de compte
donc ya pas autre chose dans les
inventeurs contient aujourd'hui
l'essentiel des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre que nous occasionne on ne sont
pas mesurés ça c'est autre chose
également qu'il faut avoir bien en fait
elles ne sont pas mesurés parce que si
vous vouliez mesurer la totalité de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
faudrait par exemple qui est un capteur
de co2 sur chaque pot d'échappement de
chaque voiture
il faudrait qu'il ya un capteur de
méthane sur chaque vache il faudrait
qu'ils aient un capteur de méthane sur
chaque rizières il faudrait qu'ils aient
un capteur de méthane sur chaque mine de
charbon
il faudrait qu'ils aient un capteur de
co2 sur chaque chaudière de bâtiments
etc etc
quand vous voyez bien que il faudrait
qu'il ya un capteur de protoxyde d'azoté
au dessus de chaque champ donc
évidemment les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre avec cette difficulté ne sont
jamais mesuré en fait ces émissions de
gaz à effet de serre elles sont
calculées
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
une incertitude et donc la manière dont
on les calcule c'est assez simple on
prend des données d'activité et que l on
est capable de mesurer alors les données
d'activité c'est par exemple un nombre
d'hectares cultivés ça on sait mesurer
où par exemple une quantité de carburant
acheté ça rend cette mesure et où par
exemple une quantité de voitures qui
circulent çà on sait de mesurer aussi où
par exemple une quantité de bifteck que
vous avez mangé corde on comprend des
trucs qu'on sait déjà mesuré dans le
monde qui nous entoure et on va calculer
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
partir de ces quantités là qu'on a
mesurée et de ce qu'on appelle un
facteur d'émission qui est représentatif
du processus moyens
émission qui prend place quand vous avez
l'unité physique que vous êtes en train
de regarder alors le facteur d'émission
il est en général soient mesurés soit
lui même calcul est un exemple idiot de
mesures
un exemple idiot de mesures c'est à vous
regarder le fonctionnement d'un moteur
vous regardez combien d'essence vous
mettez dans le moteur et vous mesurer
pour de vrai parce qu'on peut le mesurer
pour de vrai avec un bond et c'est la
quantité de co2 qui sort du pot
d'échappement et bien ce lien de cause à
conséquence entre telle quantité
d'essence rentrer telle quantité de co2
sort une fois que vous l'avez mesurer
une fois vous dit dès que j'aurai une
voiture quelque part qui consomment de
l'essence
j'ai le même lien de cause à effet entre
l'essence qui rentrait de co2 qui sort
d'accord et donc là vous avez avec une
analyse fabriquer un facteur d'émission
les facteurs élémentaires sont en
général le résultat de données
d'observation je vous en montrer un
certain nombre derrière
et après quand vous voulez faire des
facteurs sophistiqués par exemple un
repas à la cafétéria ici à ce moment
bien évidemment ça va être déjà le
résultat de calculs compliqués que vous
allez faire sur la base de facteurs
élémentaire donc exactement comme une
comptabilité monétaire une comptabilité
carbone est quelque chose qui est chaîné
c'est à dire que les valeurs de ce que
vous avez à laval dépendent de la
manière dont vous est pris pour calculer
les valeurs qui sont à la bombe
donc les premiers facteurs d'émissions
les plus importants c'est ceux qui sont
près de la matière je brûle un litre
d'essence je brûle la kg de charbon et
cetera
puis ceux qui sont encore très près de
la matière mais juste derrière j'extrais
à une tonne de minerai de fer ou bien je
réduis une tonne de minerai de fer etc
et plus et aller vers des produits
manufacturés et plus le facteur
d'émission sera le résultat d'un calcul
est pas du tout le résultat d'une
données d'observation plus vous vous
éloignez des flux des flux
initiaux juste un petit rappel
aujourd'hui on a coutume de d'utiliser
une unité de mesure qui est l'équivalent
co2 mais au moment où j'ai démarré ce
cours il ya dix ans l'unité de mesure
qui était la plus courante c'était
l'équivalent carbone alors pourquoi
c'était l'équivalent carbone parce que
l'équivalent carbone a l'avantagé d'être
très simple pour relier émissions et
extractions puisque quand vous et quand
vous extrayez un atome de carbone d'un
réservoir de pétrole et que vous en
faites du co2 correctement quand vous
extrayez 1 kg de carbone d'un réservoir
de pétrole et vous en faites du co2 ça
faisait 1 kg équivalent carbone de gaz à
effet de serre donc c'était très très
simple on avait une correspondance un
pour un mais comme les industriels ont
commencé à mesurer leur co2 puis
d'autres activités du coup la
comptabilité maintenant s'est déplacée
vers le co2 et pour faire le lien avec
le carbone et bien il faut / 44 12e
si de temps en temps vous voyez ce genre
de choses voilà donc il faut fait
attention de temps en temps les
physiciens eu et continue à compter en
carbone quand vous regardez les
inventaires d'émissions
vous avez des paies ta g de carbone
c'est à dire des millions de tonnes qui
va et maryvonne vous voulez donc les
physiciens a continué à compter en
carbone alors que les agents économiques
content co2 donc fait attention à pas
vous faire avoir
il ya un rapport 44 12e entre les entre
les deux alors maintenant je vais vous
montrer un certain nombre de facteurs
d'émission qui sont le résultat soit de
données d'observation sur un jour on a
vraiment fait des trucs en laboratoire
soit derrière qui sont des résultats de
calculs plus ou moins sophistiquées donc
là en gros vous avez essentiellement des
données d'observation et ça concerne les
choses qui brûle et qui nous permette
d'avoir de l'énergie donc ici vous avez
des combustibles solides donc là vous
voyez tourbe limite ça c'est des
combustibles solides de mauvaise qualité
huiles de schiste j'en ai parlé un tout
petit peu au moment du cours sur les
combustibles fossiles
les huiles de schiste c'est pas le che
lol c'est ce qu'on appelle le schiste
bitumineux terrain kérogène qui a pas
permis d'être pyrolyse et et qu'il faut
chauffer à la main pour qu'il ait pour
en extraire des quais du des
combustibles et donc vous avez
évidemment comme il faut le chauffer un
très mauvais rendement énergétique et
donc vous avez de très fortes émissions
par unité à l'arrivée donc ce que vous
voyez ici c'est des combustibles solides
puis vous avez les combustibles liquides
puis vous avez les combustibles gazeux
ce que vous voyez c'est bien évidemment
sans grande surprise tous les
combustibles fossiles
quels qu'ils soient émettent du co2 ce
que vous voyez également c'est que à
chaque fois que vous passez d'un
combustible à la catégorie juste en
dessous qui émet un peu moins vous
gagnez 25 à 30%
donc quand vous passez du charbon au
pétrole a même quantité d'énergie
thermique libérez-vous gagné 25 à 30% et
quand vous passez du pétrole au gaz à
nouveau vous gagnez 25 à 30% par unité
d'énergie thermique
ici vous voyez apparaître quelque chose
qui est déjà quelque chose de composites
vous voyez apparaître biocarburants avec
déforestation alors biocarburants avec
déforestation s'est déjà composite pas
ce que ça veut dire que vous avez tenu
compte des émissions de production du
biocarburant
je vous en ai un peu parlé pendant le
cours sur les énergies renouvelables
pour faire des biocarburants faire des
cultures
donc il faut produire des engrais azotés
faire passer le tracteur faire pousser
le maïs ou colza récolter tout ce truc
là soit le presser si c'est des huiles
soit le distiller 6 et d'éthanol et
c'est tout ça ça vous occasionne des
émissions donc vous avez des émissions
vous allez retrouver là-dedans mais vous
avez une deuxième catégorie des missions
vous allez retrouver là-dedans c'est que
si ces agrocarburants ont poussé sur des
surfaces qui ont été déforester pour
l'occasion ou que vous avez engendrer de
la déforestation indirects donc vous
remplacer des cultures alimentaires etc
ailleurs que la déforestation va
permettre de refaire des cultures
alimentaires et bien à ce moment il faut
tenir compte du fait que cette
déforestation est aussi une source
d'émissions
est ce que vous voyez ici c'est qu'à
partir du moment où pour faire des agro
durant on est obligé de déforester c'est
pire que si on utilisait du pétrole donc
utiliser du pétrole fera part de
remplacer du pétrole par des
agrocarburants qui nécessite de la
déforestation
c'est pire que d'utiliser du pétrole oui
si vous déforester pas ça rentre pas
dedans là je dis c'est si la
déforestation ballon ah non alors cette
déforestation elle est imputée sur 50
ans ou 40 j'ai pu enfin bon elle est
imputée sur une durée sur une durée
longue
non c'est pas l'année de la
déforestation en passer par là je peux
vous dire que graphique passe le plafond
non c'est pas ça la correspondance de 1
point c'est un kilowattheure
d'électricité au charbon fait un kilo de
co2 mais c'est de l'électricité au
charbon c'est pas du kilowattheure
thermique donc pour là pour passer au
kilowattheure électrique faut faire
intervenir le rendement de carnot
d'accord donc faux / 04 pour avoir le
contenu du kilowattheure électrique
enfin bull en l'occurrence du
mégawattheure l'état faites attention
parce que ça aussi c'est piégeux
c'est très très fréquent que les gens
confondent les kilowattheures thermique
et les kilowattheure électrique 1 quand
même un tout petit un tout petit delta
entre les entre les deux voilà donc ce
que pardon bien évidemment quand vous
voyez ça une des choses que vous vous
dites c'est que pour décarbonés nos
activités une des possibilités est
évidemment c'est de passer des énergies
de gauche vers les énergies de droite en
évitant soigneusement donc il faut qu'on
ait un petit effet quantique qui nous
fasse passer à travers les deux par là
des biocarburants avec déforestation
dont on ne veut pas mais sinon dès qu'on
arrive à passer des énergies de gauche
vers les énergies de droite à
consommation constante
on a gagné un petit quelque chose sur
les émissions en ce qui concerne
l'électricité
on y vient et bien ici vous avez le
facteur d'émission d'un certain nombre
d'électricien et ce facteur d'émission
donc là en l'occurrence c'est par
kilowattheure électrique au fond par
mégawattheure électrique ce facteur
d'émission
il est très dépendant de la manière dont
l'électricien va faire son électricité
donc quand il est à gauche par exemple
celui là c'est qui fait essentiellement
du charbon
et quand il est à droite ici c'est qu'il
a essentiellement soit de l'hydraulique
soit du nucléaire c'est comme ça que ça
se lit cette courbe donc là vous
comprenez aussi que de passer du charbon
puis du gaz à l'hydroélectricité et au
nucléaire est aussi un moyen fait aux
énergies renouvelables est aussi un
moyen de faire baisser le facteur
d'émission de l'électricité quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui soit dit en passant
le facteur d'émission de l'électricité
moyen d'un certain nombre de pays que
vous avez ici avec la part de
l'hydroélectricité et du nucléaire dans
le mix
vous voyez que vous avez une relation
raisonnablement inverse donc à l'instant
où je vous parle là c'est encore valable
il ya quelques exceptions qui sont le
danemark
il ya une petite exception mais encore
le facteur d'émission de la production
électrique est en gros une fonction
inverse de la part de la guerre et de
l'hydroélectricité que vous avez dans le
fameux renouvelables pardon donc le
danemark c'est pas dur n'est pas d'y
drôme et sinon pour les autres c'est
essentiellement du renouveau et le
brésil c'est essentiellement de l'hydro
ici la suisse essentiellement de l'hydro
la norvège s'est essentiellement diderot
la suède s'est essentiellement de
l'hydro la france et diderot donc à part
le danemark est un peu le magne
globalement vous avez une relation
inverse entre hydro et nucléaires et
facteur d'émission voilà donc ça c'est
si je regarde beaucoup de pays dans le
monde
vous avez une grande variété je vais pas
y revenir
alors après vous avez également des
facteurs des missions élémentaires dans
la production des matériaux de base
quand vous faites une tonne d'acier vous
avez été chercher du minerai vous avez
besoin d'eux pour sa 2e d'engins de
mines
et puis surtout vous allez avoir besoin
de charbon charbon spéciale qui
s'appelle du coq pour réduire votre
minerai de fer dont vous avez la bonne
molécule d'oxydé de fer qui est réduite
par du carbone est évidemment le carbone
oxydes essai du co2 et il part dans
l'atmosphère donc vous avez pour faire
du fer vous allait émettre du co2 pour
faire des métaux d'une manière générale
de manière générale pardon vous allait
émettre du co2 une bonne partie des
métaux aujourd'hui sont faits dans des
fours et ses fours pour partie d'entre
eux sont alimentés par de l'électricité
par exemple et fouras nickel sont
alimentés par de l'électricité
en ce qui concerne les fours à cuivre
sont également pour partie alimenté par
de l'électricité quand vous fabriquer de
l'aluminium
je vais en détail est juste un peu après
vous utilisez également des grandes
quantités d'électricité parce que
l'aluminium se fabrique par électrolyse
de l'aluminé et donc c'est
essentiellement l'aluminium
l'électricité comptent pour 30 à 40 %
des coûts de production très gros
consommateurs d'électricité une fonderie
d'aluminium et comme vous allez utiliser
donc à la fois des engins de mines de
l'énergie carbonées pour réduire les
molécules qui sont oxydés et
éventuellement d'électricité pour porter
à haute température
eh bien vous avez sans grande surprise
des émissions dans la production de tout
un tas de matériaux de base
alors vous voyez que dans tout ce que je
vous ai montré là le plus émissifs c'est
l'aluminium a suivi de près par le
nickel mais je ne vous ai pas montré
lors considérablement plus émissifs par
unité de poids je vous montre pas les
diamants extrêmement émissifs par unité
de poids ou les terres rares qui sont
également raisonnablement émissifs par
unité de poids si vous allez chercher de
ça donc le
mais par contre on fait pas des grandes
quantités donc les émissions de
l'industrie de production de matériaux
de base dans les métaux les émissions
les plus importantes au monde c'est la
syrie papa 4 % des émissions mondiales
de gaz à effet de serre et dans les
minéraux non métalliques sexy mans avec
à peu près 6 % des émissions mondiales
de gaz à effet de serre donc du côté de
ce qui n'est pas les métaux c'est le
ciment qui produit le plus en valeur
absolue sur terre et du côté des métaux
sélassié mais par contre par unité de
poids évidemment c'est pas nécessaire
quand comme ça que ça se passe écrit
donc ces facteurs d'émission la peu ils
font l'objet d'analysés qui reste des
analyses de terrain un peu détaillé
oui
ces mots chaleur parce que pour faire au
plastique vous avez besoin de raffiner
du pétrole
ensuite vous avez besoin d'un truc qui
s'appelle un vapocraqueur qui comme son
nom l'indiqué craque donc a besoin de
hautes températures
ensuite vous allez faire des monomères
ces monomères vous allez les polymérisé
là dessus vous avez encore besoin de
chaleur enfin vous allez les mettre en
forme
alors ça c'est quand même moins de
chaleur mais c'est de la chaleur quand
même donc en fait vous avez des gros
besoins de chaleur dans toute la chaîne
de la fabrication du plastique
voilà maintenant quelque chose qui vous
montre que en ce qui concerne les
matériaux de base
vous avez pour certains d'entre eux une
grande variabilité du facteur d'émission
qui est possible alors pas pour tous
quand vous faites de l'acier primaire
donc je le redis les émissions de
l'acier primaires c'est essentiellement
réduire avec du carbone de l'oxydé de
fer réduire avec du carbone de l'oxydé
de fer vous avez un rapport ce tokyo
métriques que vous pouvez pas violer
encore dans une molécule d'oxydé de fer
et fait 2 ou 3 vous avez besoin d'un 25
atomes de carbone pour réduire la
molécule et vous ferez jamais - ce qui
veut dire que vous avez une limite basse
aux émissions en dessous desquels vous
pouvez descendre tant qu' on fabrique du
fer ou la fonte plus exactement en
réduisant du minerai de fer
donc on fait ça vous pouvez pas
descendre en dessous d'un certain niveau
il ya d'autres procédés pour lesquels
d'autres procédés de fabrication de
métaux pour lesquelles vous avez une
variabilité qui est beaucoup plus grande
et l'aluminium est un cas très
intéressant parce que l'essentiel des
émissions de la fabrication de
l'aluminium c'est les émissions qui sont
liées à la production de l'électricité
qui va être utilisé pour l'électrolysé
si vous allez en australie où comme vous
le savez j'espère que je ne vais vexer
personne dans cette salle
ils sont charbonné jusqu'au cou et bien
vous allez avoir en ce qui concerne la
production de l'aluminium quasiment un
facteur 10 par rapport si vous faites
les lectrices de l'aluminium ans
islande ou en france parce que dans un
cas vous allez l'islande a énormément de
fonderie d'aluminium
parce que comme ils ont énormément
d'hydroélectricité et donc de
l'électricité pas cher et bien il
accueille par ailleurs ils ont peu près
de l'espace et enfin ils sont en bord de
ils peuvent mettre des fonderies près
des ports dont klaus et pas cher
d'acheminer du minerai en grande
quantité eh bien ils ont développé une
industrie significative dans la fonderie
de l'aluminium est donc là ce que vous
voyez c'est que selon que vous êtes au
meilleur niveau avec de l'électricité
hydraulique et nucléaire ou au pire
niveau avec du charbon
eh bien vous vous baladez entre un peu
moins de 2 et plus de 20 tonnes de co2
par tonne d'aluminium
il ya un petit talon irréductibles ici
tout en bas qui est que pour électrolyse
et de l'aluminium
aujourd'hui on utilise des anneaux dans
carbone qui sont même fait en coke de
pétrole
une société française qui fait ce genre
de choses et sézanne aude se consomme au
cours du processus d'électrolysé et
céanothes se consomme au cours du
processus d électrolyse en donnant
notamment des gaz fluorés
parce que le bain d'aluminé il ya des
adjuvants fluorés et c'est à d'autres ce
qu'on se consomme en vous donnant cf 4
essais de m6 qui sont des gaz à effet de
serre extrêmement puissant donc c'est
pas émis en très grande quantité mais
c'est
extrêmement puissant et donc ça ça fait
un talon liées au procès ce qui est
compliqué enlevée alors maintenant on va
regarder des facteurs d'émission qui
sont un peu plus composite c'est à dire
que en fait pour faire les facteurs
d'émission que je vous montre là il a
déjà fallu embaucher une société comme
la mienne ou un concurrent pour faire un
calcul un peu complet et un peu
sophistiqué à partir d'autres facteurs
d'émission qui avait déjà été créés ici
vous avez les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui sont liées au fait de
déplacer une personne sur 1 km c'est ça
qu'on appelle un passager kilomètre donc
si c'est une personne sur 10 km s'est
dit passager kilomètre 10 personnes sur
1 km s'est aussi dit passagers
kilomètres donc un passager kilomètre en
fonction du mode de transport vous avez
ici un premier qu'est ce que je veux
dire première case en vert clair qu'ils
excellent fabrication fabrication c'est
la fabrication du moyen de transport
quand vous roulez en voiture vous avez
besoin de fabriquer la voiture votre
voiture pèse entre une tonne et une
tonne et demi là dedans vous avez 70 %
d'acier vous avez un petit 10 % de
plastique et autres dérivés vous avez
des textiles vous avez des fluides vous
avez de l'électronique
vous avez aujourd'hui dans une voiture
l'équivalent de deux à trois ordinateurs
et évidemment il a fallu fabriquer tout
ça si je regarde les émissions de
fabrication d'une voiture aujourd'hui
c'est de l'ordre de 6 tonnes de co2 par
tonne de voitures votre voiture va faire
deux cent mille kilomètres sur sa durée
de vie 6 tonne de co2 / 200 mille
kilomètres ça me fait combien de grammes
de co2 par kilomètre
je vous le dis au début du cours si vous
arrivez à faire des règles de trois les
calculs dans deux vendeurs rugby un
homme heureux
pardon six cent mille pardons 6 tonnes /
200 milles 6 / 3-6 / 2 pardon ça peut
faire 5
on est d'accord donc ça vous fait 30
grammes de co2 par kilomètre d'accord
ensuite la en l'occurrence et 25 mai
ensuite vous avez un casque bleu là qui
s'appelle hamon alors à mon qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc là c'est les
émissions de production du carburant
parce que votre voiture ne roule pas au
pétrole brut
elle roule au carburant raffiné alors
aujourd'hui si c'est de l'essence c'est
très bien si tu diesel c'est très mal
mais au carburant raffiné pour raffiner
pour extraire transporter et raffiner le
pétrole
il a fallu et m là aussi des gaz à effet
de serre puisque une partie du pétrole
est parti d'un processus
et ça ça représente en gros 15 % des
émissions de combustion qui ont lieu
dans la voiture bien évidemment votre
voiture elle va brûler en direct du
carburant dont vous avez ici les
émissions de combustion et enfin il ya
des endroits où je vous ai pas
discriminer tout ça donc ici vous avez
un tout compris qui évite de vous faire
la part des choses
alors ce que vous voyez ici c'est que en
fonction du fait que vous ayez de
l'essence ou du gazole vous avez des
émissions qui sont très voisines un peu
légèrement enfin très légèrement
inférieur pour le gazole mais très
voisines vous voyez également que vous
avez des émissions qui aujourd'hui avec
le taux de remplissage actuel des
voitures sont de l'ordre de 150 grammes
par passager kilomètre
si vous regardez la documentation
fournie par le constructeur pour cette
voiture là il va pas vous dire 150
il va probablement vous dire 80 il va
vous dire 80 pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'il va vous raconter des
carabistouilles sur la consommation
réelle de la voiture donc il va vous
dire elle concerne 4 litres aux 100 en
cycle urbain et alors que vous regardez
le votre vraie consommation et c6 et la
deuxième chose c'est que le constructeur
ne tient pas compte ni de ça ni de sa
est donc le résultat des courses c'est
que pour avoir les vraies émissions de
co2 de ce que vous faites quand vous
êtes en voiture vous prenez les
émissions normalisée que vous donne
votre constructeur et mon x 2 voies là
et ça ça vous donne la vérité vraie
comme disait l'autre
ensuite ici vous avez d'autres facteurs
d'émission d'envoyer par exemple le bus
ratp en moyenne gypa aux heures de
pointe mais en moyenne il aimait à peu
près comme une personne en voiture parce
que il ya une bonne partie de la journée
où il évident où il est quasiment vide
voilà donc vous avez d'autres bons la
moto ça émet en moyenne plus dur est
quelquefois c'est pas bien faut le dire
à personne
il m'est arrivé de prendre une moto taxi
pour aller à une matinale de radio est
donc évidemment j'ai demandé au
chauffeur de la moto taxi kong a
conservé sa moto taxi j'ai aussi demandé
comment ça peut se dire j'ai été
estomaqué est ce que vous savez comment
il s'appelle une grosse moto l'agent
goldwyn 600 kg la deux chevaux dans
laquelle j'ai appris à conduire en peser
500 600 kg et où j'ai demandé comment il
faisait pour la relever cet orateur mais
j'arrive et son truc consomme plus que
ma voiture je m'en sors pas souvent mais
consomme plus que ma voiture donc
contrairement à l'idée qu'on peut s'en
faire la grosse poteau c'est pas parce
que c'est un petit engin compact j'ai
envie de dire que ça consomme moins
qu'une voiture les grosses motos
concerne globalement plus que les
citadines
oui
et
[Musique]
ils sont censés le faire absolument oui
tout à fait donc il ya d'énormes utac
enfin maintenant qu'ils ont été
remplacés par d'autres normes qui sont
censés être plus proche de la vérité
parce que vous alliez jusqu'à 40 %
d'écart entre ce que disait le
constructeur sur la consommation de son
véhicule et ce qui se passait dans la
vraie vie
moi je peux vous dire quand la voiture
cinq fois par an pour partir en vacances
mais les cinq fois par an ou deux la
prends je peux vous dire je suis là y
arriver sur l'ordinateur de bord a
essayé de voir comment je peux arriver
au truc le plus bas possible
jamais une fois dans ma vie je ne suis
arrivé à la consommation de la
documentation jamais roule à 120 sur
l'autoroute
rien rien n'y fait ça marche pas
donc voila mais parce que à ce moment là
vous êtes seul en voiture vous êtes sur
du plat n'y a pas de vent et pas de
pente et pas de ceux ci a pas de cela
vous vous êtes en sous régime c'est
pourquoi vous faites tout ce qu'il faut
vous n'avez pas les bons pneus ils sont
pas gonflés pareil enfin vous avez un
milliard d'astuces qui sont faites pour
que ça concerne donc il ya vraiment un
moment où la voiture concept ça et c'est
pas quand vous êtes dedans vous voyez
ici qu en ce qui concerne le train vous
avez globalement en france des émissions
beaucoup plus faible cela étant si vous
prenez un ter au diesel vous commencez à
avoir quelque chose qui est significatif
et il se trouve que quand vous êtes dans
un ter au diesel malle remplie il vaut
beaucoup mieux être dans un autocar bien
remplies ça émet beaucoup moins de co2
ans qui concilie s'il est au gazole je
me rappelle une fois avoir pris un thé
vert au gazole magnifique du reste pour
aller de besançon à neuchâtel est
absolument magnifique concept de le
faire tant qu'il sera là mais par contre
on était je pars à quatre dans le train
dans le teaser au diesel en question je
pense que c'était un des plus mauvais
bilans carbone au km2 mali aurait
beaucoup mieux valu que je roule en
porsche sur le même itinéraire en vélo
électrique donc le donc voilà donc donc
si vous avez un mode ferrer donc
normalement efficace mais fonctionnant
aux hydrocarbures il mal remplie vous
pouvez quand même avoir un facteur
d'émission qui est pas complètement
négligeable
et soit dit en passant les mêmes causes
produisant les mêmes effets si vous êtes
en allemagne donc avec une électricité
qui est beaucoup plus carbonées que la
française est bien en allemagne un train
pas très bien rempli et un autocar bien
remplie sont au même niveau en ce qui
concerne les émissions par passager et
par kilomètre
bon ben voilà ici c'est exactement ce
que j'avais à vous dire ici vous avez
les émissions par passager kilomètre
dans un certain nombre de pays
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que la
suisse et la suède sont les mieux placés
de très loin
nous on n'est pas là évidemment sinon ça
serait pas drôle
alors la raison pour laquelle la suède
et la suisse sont très bien rentrer très
bien doté oui
alors c'est significativement plus haut
je regarde si j'ai une slide après qui
donne ça oui j'ai ça après je vous
montrais donc ici vous avez des vous
voyez que les émissions peuvent varier
alors ça varie en fonction du mix
électrique du pays
si vous êtes dans un pays dans lequel
l'électricité carbonée où vous avez
beaucoup de trains au diesel
eh bien ça peut être élevé par exemple
je suis allé à copenhague en train
croyant bien faire on s'est bien fait
par rapport à l'avion et il se trouve
que une partie du trajet entre hambourg
et copenhague se fait quand on fait le
trajet de jour se fait dans un dans un
train ou diesel qui par ailleurs faire
un truc et qui en rajoute encore aux
émissions c'est qu'à un moment il rentre
dans un ferry pour traverser un bras de
mer
rentré dans le rang très longue série
débarque tout le monde du train ils vous
envoient saucissonné au premier étage
donc vous avez double peine pour les
émissions mais donc vous pouvez avoir en
fonction de la part de diesel dans la
motorisation et du mix électrique du
pays et du taux de remplissage des
émissions qui varient fortement
la suède il quand je trouve que la
suisse comme toutes les cases
l'électricité est très décarbonés et le
taux de remplissage des trains est
excellent et c'est excellent pas juste
parce que les suisses sont des gens
formidables mais parce que comme ils ont
un pays très montagneux
ils ont urbaniser en linéaire en fond de
vallée
parce que l'étalement urbain sur les
flancs de montagne c'est compliqué et
donc tous les gens habitent pas loin de
la gare d'accord donc vous pouvez avoir
un taux de remplissage des trains
extrêmement élevé quand vous êtes dans
le plat pays qui est le nôtre aussi un
peu et bien et que vous êtes dans un
pays de plaine
à ce moment vous urbaniser en étoile et
en étoile tout de suite vous allez avoir
une densité d'habitants au kilomètre
carré beaucoup trop faible pour que cela
soit rentable d'avoir des trains partout
alors que si vous êtes urbaniser en
linéaire le long d'un fonds de vallée
vous gardez une densité élevée
d'habitants au kilomètre carré
tout le long de la voie donc vous pouvez
avoir un train qui est rentable oui
oui alors ça dépend ce qu'il avait sur
la petite ligne et sa dépense à quel
horizon vous projeter dans l'avenir
si vous regardez à très court terme vous
fermez la petite ligne et la petite
ligue était empruntée par quatre
pingouins le matin et 3000 soir et le
truc était au diesel voilà en
l'occurrence il vaut beaucoup mieux que
les gens prennent leur voiture quelque
part ça ça va faire moins d'émissions si
vous raisonnez à l'envers et vous vous
dites non non c'est un effet d'annoncé
un élément d'aménagement du territoire
donc je garde le train comme ça les gens
vont déménager et se mettent à habiter
près de la gare quand le pétrole va
devenir plus contraints à ce moment vous
renverser le raisonnement donc ça dépend
de l'horizon de temps que vous prenez et
ça dépend des autres trucs qui se passe
autour
donc la mauvaise nouvelle pour rousset
qui a pas de réponse simple à cette
question alors on recommence
mais cette fois ci on fait intervenir
l'avion alors vous voyez que en ce qui
concerne l'avion vous avez globalement
des émissions notamment en ce qui
concerne le court courriers qui sont
significativement plus élevé que ce que
vous avez en
en voiture mais le pire
oui c'est rigolo c'est d'aller sur le
queen mary
si vous allez sur le queen mary
c'est pas bien du tout parce que ce truc
consomme énormément globalement retenez
que en ce qui concerne l'avion en
seconde
vous allez consommer à peu près autant
de carburant que en voiture mais par
contre évidemment pour des trajets qui
seront en moyenne considérablement plus
long donc si on regarde les émissions
non pas par passager kilomètre mais par
trajet en avion vous êtes un facteur
sont au dessus d'un trajet en voiture
donc quand vous franchissez la porte
d'un aéroport pour monter dans un avion
vous allez en moyenne émettre 100 fois
plus que quand vous feront quand vous
ouvrez une portière de voiture pour
monter dedans
dans les heures qui vont suivre
voilà la réponse à la question qui avait
été posé sur le train donc ici vous avez
un graphique dans lequel vous avez
toutes les émissions qui sont prises en
compte et en ce qui concerne le tgv vous
avez dans la construction
d'infrastructures donc pour un pour un
une ligne récente alors ce que vous
voyez c'est que même en faisant
intervenir l'infrastructure le train
reste quand même plus performant que la
voiture
vous êtes en contact faire faire le taux
de remplissage est bien meilleur et
l'électricité est décarbonée alors que
le carburant ne l'est pas donc si vous
êtes en france il ya juste pas photo si
vous avez le choix entre le tgv la
voiture et l'avion c'est le train qui
remporte tous les suffrages
en ce qui concerne les émissions de co2
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
peut-être du passé récemment dans
l'actualité une proposition de loi qui a
été déposé au parlement et qui vise à
interdire une partie des vols
domestiques en avion à partir du moment
où le train ne vous rallonge pas le
trajet de plus de 2h30 alors je précise
que c'est le trajet limiter au seul vol
mais quand vous allez prendre l'avion
vous avez du temps avant parce qu'il
faut aller jusqu'à l'aéroport
donc si vous partez de la ville il ya le
temps pour aller jusqu'à l'aéroport le
temps où vous poireauter ou fait pas
prier dans l'aéroport et
symétriquement de l'autre côté si vous
avez une valise le temps que vous allez
pouvoir voter pour attendre votre valise
puis ensuite le temps que vous allez
prendre pour aller de l'aéroport jusque
dans la ville où vous allez et bien tout
ce temps mis bout à bout c'est au bas
mot une heure et demie à deux heures si
robin 1h30 à 2h donc ce qui veut dire
que si le delta de temps dans la
proposition de loi c'est deux heures et
demie en fait le temps que vous allez
vraiment passé en plus c'est plutôt de
l'ordre de la demi heure
voilà c'est juste pour un petit à petit
rectificatif et 7 proposé ce projet de
loi est très exactement basé sur le
différentiel des missions que vous avez
la race est à dire qu il dit bon dans un
certain nombre de cas de figure on
demande aux gens de prendre le train et
à l'avion
oui
non c'est un impact parce que encore une
fois vous voyez ici que en ce qui
concerne le train vous êtes à 30 grammes
par passager kilomètre en ce qui
concerne l'avion vous êtes à 150
là je vais vous parler rapidement de ce
qu'on appelle le kyoto donc vous avez
quand même un facteur 5
et si vous êtes sur une voie qui est
déjà amortis donc si vous faites par
exemple l'appareil clermont ferrand sur
une voie de chemin de fer qui n'est pas
tgv qui existe depuis longtemps ou d'ici
quelques dizaines d'années à paris lyon
sur une voie qui a été amorti si vous
regardez un coût marginal en fait avoir
déjà amortis quelque part et bien à ce
moment vous avez plutôt non pas un
facteur 5 mais plutôt un facteur 20 en
faveur du train donc oui ça fait quand
même quelques millions de tonnes de co2
dans l'histoire le nombre de passagers
qui les impacts et est faible et par
ailleurs alors vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui sont en transit en
correspondance et par ailleurs vous
impact et globalement des gens pour
qu'ils aient pas un besoin vital encore
75% du trafic aérien s'est des loisirs
où aller rendre visite à des amis
personnellement j'ai un peu de mal à
mettre ça dans la catégorie besoin vital
si vous voulez donc si vous allez
poireauter une heure de plus pour rendre
visite à des amis ou partir en vacances
c'est enfin c'est pas que ça va faire
pleurer en tout cas il ya il ya un il ya
un une gêne qui est somme toute très
minime pour un bénéfice par contre qui
est raisonnablement enfin qui sur ces
trajets là est très significatif
vous avez en gros un million de vous
avez en gros un million de passagers par
an qui sont concernés par la mesure qui
est proposé qui laisse de côté la plus
grosse ligne domestique française qui
est de paris toulouse et qui est
probablement une des plus grosses qui
est son domestique en europe où il ya
plus de 2 millions de passagers par an
bon mais si ça ne tenait qu'à moi je le
connais aussi dedans parce que vous avez
un frein qui fait paris toulouse moi
j'ai un collaborateur qui habite à
toulouse depuis la création de carbone 4
ça fait dix ans qu'il habite à toulouse
et ça fait dix ans qu'ils gardent pareil
en train et il est toujours vivant aux
dernières nouvelles
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le queen mary st donc
c'est un truc de croisière si vous
faites comme dicaprio dans titanic se
dire que vous en vous en passer les gens
en troisième classe où il serait un peu
le facteur d'émission
après il faut voir aussi que lassé des
navires à passagers donc a pas de fret
mais si vous êtes le passage est
marginal sur un cargo de banane on va
évidemment pas du tout faire le même
calcul lavaud émissions seront beaucoup
plus basse il y avait encore une
question non j'ai pu oui c'est
exactement la question du fret
le ferry deux jours en fait ils prendre
des passagers dans cette affaire là le
ferry nuit prend aussi du fret voilà le
voilà vous voyez qu'en france le karma
kron pour remplacer des trains c'est pas
une bonne idée pour les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre maintenant on va aller
un peu ailleurs donc on va aller par
exemple en pologne alors le pologne ce
n'est pas si long tgv pour le moment on
aurait pu aller en allemagne mais ce que
vous voyez c'est que en pologne
il vaut mieux se balader en car que en
train à cause du fait que l'électricité
est au charbon
si le train n'est pas bien remplie donc
vous voyez le
le train ici n'est remplie que aux trois
quarts enfin cela étant et le carré des
jardins passagers
dans tous les cas de figure c'est mieux
que la voiture mais vous voyez que
l'écart entre les deux est
considérablement plus faibles et autant
en france c'est l'infrastructure qui
domine le fait d'avoir construit la
ligne autant en pologne
ce qui domine c'est le fait de faire
avancer le train oui oui pardon or kyoto
c'est les effets sur le climat de
l'aérien qui ne sont pas dans les
inventaires d'émissions alors dans les
inventaires d'émissions je vous ai dit
on compte le co2 le méthane le protoxyde
d'azoté les gaz fluorés
vous ne comptez pas la vapeur d'eau or
il se trouve que l'avion en régime de
croisière ils votent ils volent pardon à
la limite de la troposphère series vol à
la limite entre la couche atmosphérique
la plus basse celle qui touche le sol et
qui s'appelle la troposphère et la
couche fuyante qui s'appelle la
stratosphère
il vole à cet endroit là parce qu'à cet
endroit là vous avez une inversion de
température et c'est là que en terme
d'optimum portance vitesse etc
c'est là qu'ils se trouvent bien or il
se trouve que le kérosène utilisé dans
les avions et mais de la vapeur d'eau
quand on brûle ça engendre la vapeur
d'eau une partie de cette vapeur d'eau
va passer dans la stratosphère et à
cause de la limite convectifs que
j'avais expliqué pendant le cours sur le
changement climatique des nuages à la
tropopause cette vapeur qui rentre dans
la stratosphère elle va mettre longtemps
avant d'en sortir
or la vapeur d'eau est un gaz à effet de
serre donc ça va contribuer un
supplément de réchauffement climatique
vous avez également les traînées de
condensation des avions est aux huîtres
et les conversations des avions il va
aller très vite condensation des avions
ont le même actif de forçage radiatif
que les cyrus c'est à dire que leur
effet de serre l'emportent sur leurs
effets réflexif donc les traînées de
condensation des avions accroissent le
changement enfin le forçage radiatif aux
états unis juste après le fameux 11
septembre
vous vous rappelez du fameux 11
septembre oui vous étiez jeune
c'est le jour où les deux tours du world
trade center son parti au tapis juste
après les etats-unis ont interdit toute
circulation aérienne sur le territoire
pendant plusieurs jours eh bien on a
constaté une baisse des températures
nocturnes en particulier de quelques
degrés pendant les jours où la mesure
s'est appliqué les états unis si un
quart du trafic aérien mondial donc un
quart des avions qui circulent dans le
monde se baladent à l'intérieur des
états unis
donc au moment où on a supprimé ça ça
instantanément supprimer un terme très
significative de forçage radiatif aux
états unis et donc les températures la
nuit sont baissées voilà donc ces
[ __ ] et j'appelle ça le off you tôt
parce que ça n'est pas dans les
inventaires mais l'effet de ces gaz là
se baladent n'importe où entre 20% de
surplus un doublement en fonction de la
personne qui s'exprime la manière dont
on fait les calculs etc
donc c'est pas c'est pas négligeable
c'était quelque chose de significatif
voilà maintenant des facteurs
d'émissions en ce qui concerne la
production de la nourriture alors la
production de la nourriture conduit à
plusieurs types d'émissions d'abord vous
avez besoin dans un certain nombre de
cas de figure d'engins qui consomment
directement des hydrocarbures
je suis désolé c'est en anglais mais bon
c'est comme ça voyez par exemple les
crevettes les crevettes c'est de la
pêche c'est une pêche qui est peu
sélective parce que vous vous baladez
avec des filets qui ont des petites
mailles donc vous attrapez certes des
crevettes et tout un tas de trucs qui
vous intéressent pas et donc en moyenne
la pêche à la crevette vous attrape 80%
de prises accessoires donc des trucs qui
sont pas des crevettes des tout petits
poissons et les machins et cetera que
vous allez vous donner aux pêcheurs ou
rejetés du coup la pêche à la crevette
vous avez besoin de beaucoup de diesel
par kilo de crevettes pêchées plus que
pour les autres poissons puisque le
poisson que vous avez là et les poissons
tropicaux c'est parce que vous avez des
thoniers qui sont des combats chien qui
concerne plein de carburant alors vous
allez me dire maintenant pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ya du pétrole dans le boeuf
parce que sauf erreur de ma part le
boeuf se pêche pas et qu'un bateau
qui consomment du diesel alors pourquoi
il ya du pétrole dans le boeuf
oui
oui alors absolument il ya toute la
mécanisation agricole de la nourriture
qu'on lui donne mais le poste dominant
là dedans en fait c'est pas du pétrole
et du gaz
et il sert à non il parle et pourtant
à quoi sert le gazon l'agriculture voilà
le gaz sert à faire des engrais et la
fabrication des engrais émet du co2
comme toute fabrication de tout produit
chimique la fabrication des engrais
démarre soit dit en passant avec de la
production d'hydrogène donc faire de
l'hydrogène en grande quantité on sait
très bien faire aujourd'hui
on craque du méthane et on fait ça en
chauffant donc très fort du gaz naturel
en fait c'est dur et fort match je
prends du gaz naturel qu'on mélange à de
la vapeur d'eau puis on chauffe tous
après fort et on obtient un mélange
d'hydrogène et co2 donc ça fait plein de
co2 cette histoire là derrière on fait
de la magna qui est derrière on fait des
arrêts ces engrais vont être utilisés
pour les cultures végétales qui vont
elles mêmes servir à nourrir les animaux
je rappelle que 80 % de la surface
agricole française est dévolue à la
nourriture d'animaux tout le maïs tout
les prairies la moitié du blé toute la
luzerne et c'est donc une bonne partie
l'essentiel de ce qu'on cultive en
france ne sert pas à nourrir des hommes
mais à noël des animaux
donc vous avez le gaz de la fabrication
des engrais et le pétrole de la
mécanisation de telle sorte que vous
quand vous mangez un kilo de boeuf vous
mangez un kilo d'hydrocarbures vraiment
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
mangin kg niveau carbure là dessus vous
avez un deuxième contributeur dans les
produits agricoles qui est le protoxyde
d azote
le protoxyde d'azoté vient de
toujours les engrais mais plus
précisément deux à quel moment ça se
produit à quel moment dans l'utilisation
des engrais on a des émissions de
protoxyde d azote après l'épandage
absolument quand vous mettez le
l'ammonitrate sur le sol enfin les
produits les produits azotés et durer
vous avez une petite partie de ces
produits qui sous l'effet de l'activité
microbienne se réduit et vous donne du
protoxyde d azote et enfin vous avez du
méthane pour tous les produits qui
viennent du cheptel bovin et ça ce
méthane c'est la fermentation entérique
des animaux oui parce que vous allez me
trouver la réponse tout seul
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya plus d
émissions par unité de poids dans le
fromage que dans le lait parce que oui
donc très simplement ça veut dire que
pour faire un kilo de fromage il faut
plus de 20 kg de lait voilà donc pour
être plus précis pour faire un kilo de
camembert il faut deux kilos de lait
mais pour faire un kilo de conté il en
faut 10 donc c'est pour ça que les
fromages à pâte dure par unité de
poissons plus émissifs que les fromages
à pâte molle oui
non
très bonne question pourquoi est ce que
les fruits et légumes de saison sont pas
très différents des fruits et légumes
importés
comment arrivent les tomates du maroc
non pas en bateau ou en avion
beaucoup trop cher en camion donc le
camion parle du maroc passe le détroit
de gibraltar en montrant un ferry et il
continue sa route de l'autre côté à
travers l'espagne et la france
des émissions du fret de marchandises
dans un camion c'est 15 grammes par
tonne kilomètre donc vous faire un
rapide calcul
en fait les émissions du transport liées
à un kilo de tomates qui vient du maroc
c'est pas très élevé est en tout cas
c'est beaucoup plus faible que les
émissions de production de la tomate en
france si vous la faites sous serre
chauffée pour faire un kilo de tomates
nantaise sous serres chauffées donc
toutes les tomates que vous avez acheté
jusqu en avril ou mai donc à partir des
gelées jusqu'à avril ou mai tout ce que
vous achetez ces deux tomates française
c'est de la serre chauffée à partir de
juin
vous commencez à avoir du tunnel c'est à
dire une serre qui n'est pas chauffée et
pour avoir de la vraie tomates qui à
burie normalement faut attendre juillet
donc toutes les tomates ce que vous
achetez encore une fois entre les
premières gelées et avril mais c'est
française c'est les tomates qui ont
poussé sous serres chauffées et enrichie
en co2 soit dit en passant pour faire un
kilo de tomates sous serre chauffée
il faut utiliser un kilo de gaz ça c'est
très simple un pour un donc vous voyez
ma serre local à deux c'est enfin la
tomate locale mais pas de saison là pour
le coup elle est beaucoup plus et
missive que ma tomates qui vient de loin
hors saison à condition que l ai voyagé
en bateau ou en avion et que là où elle
a été produite elles viennent pas du ch
au fait c'est pour ça qu'il faut compter
c'est bien à cela que sert la
comptabilité carbone c'est à comprendre
ce qui se passe oui
non les transports sont marginaux là
dedans sauf pour les trucs qui sont
apportées mais sinon c'est marginal
donc ils vont beaucoup mieux une banane
qui arrivent en france par bateau que 1
qu'est ce que je veux tomates qui vient
de qui vient de la serre du coin si elle
est chauffée
si c'est pas de saison ça sert à rien
donc il faut acheter local et de saison
en général c'est qu'on fait ça qu'on
vous dit mais vous savez c'est très
simple la tomate est un fruit un fruit
en général les végétaux fructifier
rarement l'hiver voilà donc pour savoir
si un truc est de saison faut en revenir
à ce qui s'appelle le bon sens
je sais qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
nécessairement le truc le mieux partagé
mais voilà une aubergine où ils
courgettes c'est également un fruit en
partie de la plante donc vous aurez pas
ça au mois de février
la salade est une feuille
donc ça une feuille vous en avez ou le
chou est une feuille bon ça vous en avez
quelques unes qui résistent en hiver par
exemple la scarole résistants
raisonnablement mais voilà le chou
résiste très bien à la gelée le poireau
aussi il faut juste renseigné et puis
vous savez quelles sont les parties de
la plante qui sont en accord avec les
racines normalement ça vous pouvez en
extraire en hiver ça reste dans le sol
c'est aussi bête que ça paris qui sont
là-bas d'abord
c'est une question de location dans un
système bovins vous avez des vaches et
des veaux du lait donc vous avez vous
savez ce qui rentre dans l'ensemble du
système c'est ce qui les nourrit vous
savez le méthane émis par l'ensemble du
système et après la question c'est
qu'est-ce que jaloux et à quoi alors si
vous avez une vache adulte et que vous
la garder en vie pour produire soit du
lait soit du veau au lieu de la
zigouiller tout de suite et de la manger
tout de suite vous allez imputé
simplement à son métabolisme annuel la
totalité de ce qu'elle produit
d'accord donc tout le lait produit par
une vache dans l'année vous allez imputé
ce assange est aboli ce manuel si la
vache vous la maintenaient en vie
simplement pour qu'elle fasse un veau à
ce moment vous allez mettre une partie
des émissions de la vache dans le veau
puisque la vache vous avez aucun intérêt
à la garder en vie pour autre chose qu
elle même
d'ailleurs vous pouvez tout de suite là
zigouiller la manger donc si la seule
raison de la garder en vie c'est de
faire un veau vous allez mettre une
partie des émissions dans le veau alors
si le veau derrière vous en faites une
bâche
évidemment le truc il avait un capital
de départ qui va s'imputer sur
l'ensemble de la durée de vie mais si
vous mangez comme vaud et là je parle
bien des races à viande un donc des
veaux qui viennent de vaches allaitantes
donc on les garde simplement pour
qu'elle fasse des veaux à ce moment vous
avez des émissions extrêmement élevé
parce que la règle d'imputation a été
construite comme ça vous pourriez très
bien avoir une autre règle d'imputation
exactement comme j'ai évoqué pour les
biocarburants la toussaint est une
affaire de règles vous pourriez dire je
regarde l'ensemble des émissions du
système bovins et ja put de manière
massique au lait et à la viande est à ce
moment ci vous imputez de manière
magique comme le veau il pèse le quart
du poids de la vache adulte et ben vous
lui impute auriez des
pardon si vous impliquer de manière
massive que la par kilo de poids le veau
et lavage serait sur un pied d'égalité
c'est il ya plein de manières de faire
ce qui est important dans cette affaire
là c'est de constater qu'en ordre de
grandeur
c'est quand même des émissions qui sont
beaucoup plus élevés que les émissions
d'un certain nombre d'autres sources de
protéines
à commencer par les petits animaux donc
en gros
manger des poules et des lapins plutôt
que de manger de la viande rouge par
unité de poids ça fait quand même
beaucoup moins oui après lafarge avance
mais oui le port ne ruminent passer un
de ses avantages
donc le port il a pas ça et par ailleurs
le port il grossit beaucoup plus vite
que le boeuf et donc vous arriver
beaucoup plus vite
il a un taux de transformation de
matière végétale en matière animale qui
est beaucoup plus efficace
d'une manière générale plus l'animal est
petit et plus haut taux de
transformation est efficace c'est pareil
pour la blague
nous voici donc avec des facteurs
d'émission dont vous avez compris qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux sont des sons
très très près des flux élémentaire et
un certain nombre d'autres facteurs
d'émission sont déjà le résultat de
calculs un peu un peu sophistiqué
maintenant que on est capable de
calculer des flux unitaire d'émission à
ce moment se pose la question de savoir
comment on les regroupe
pour les donner à des gens comme vous
pour vous en fassiez quelque chose donc
comme dans toute comptabilité
on va avoir des postes de regroupement
par exemple dans une comptabilité vous
avez un poste de regroupement qui
s'appelle salaires dans lequel vous
mettez tout ce que vous avez payé aux
gens qui travaillent dans l'entreprise
corps donc vous mettez ça dans un seul
tiroir de la commode vous les mettez par
ailleurs et vous mettez tous les
salaires dans le tiroir de la commode et
bien en ce qui concerne les inventaires
d'émissions pour les entreprises c'est
pareil vous avez un certain nombre de
postes de regroupement donc maintenant
ça ça fait l'objet d'une norme iso donc
c'est un truc qui est normalisée dans le
monde à premier poste de regroupement
pour votre entreprise concerne les
émissions directes donc ici par exemple
ça serait les éditions la chaudière vous
avez les émissions directes des sources
fixes et les émissions directes des
sources mobile après vous avez un
deuxième doublé dans les émissions
directes et excusez moi j'ai un autre
truc que j'ai oublié ses les émissions à
la fois énergétique et de procéder
ensuite vous avez un deuxième poste que
vous allez regarder qui sont les
émissions indirectes dû à l'utilisation
de l'énergie donc c'est essentiellement
les émissions des centrales électriques
pour l'électricité que vous achetez
ensuite un troisième poste va concerner
les déplacements des personnes dans
lequel vous avez deux sous ensembles en
général qui sont les déplacements pour
venir au travail et les déplacements
dans le cadre du travail
un quatrième poste concerne le fret des
marchandises
un cinquième pas pardon et la
fabrication de ce qui rentre ça c'est un
sixième vous avez un poste qui concerne
la gestion des déchets qui sortent un
autre poste qui concerne les transports
à laval et l'utilisation des produits
et enfin voila l utilisation des
produits vous avez également un dernier
poste qui correspond à la fin de vie des
produits que vous vendez par exemple si
vous vendez des journaux et bien la fin
de vie des produits vendus ça peut
correspondre à quelque chose de
significatif parce qu'à l'époque où les
journaux partait en décharge et
méthaniser en décharge parce qu'ils
ferment tel est bien le premier poste du
bilan carbone d'un fabricant de journal
ça pouvait être la méthanisation des
journaux jeter et qui métallisé en
décharge et rebelote à la bombe
évidemment ce qui rentre dans votre
entreprise
c'est le résultat du calcul que vous
avez fait à l'étagé au dessus alors
c'est poste de regroupement
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont été conçus
comme ça c'est tout simplement parce que
deux dans une entreprise vous avez pour
chacun de ces processus quelqu'un qui le
pilote ou qui au moins l'observent vous
avez dans chaque entreprise
quelqu'un qui s'occupe des
approvisionnements en énergie vous avez
toujours quelqu'un qui s'occupe de la
logistique c'est pas nécessairement le
même qui s'occupe de la logistique pour
ce qui rentre et celle pour qui sort
vous avez toujours quelqu'un qui conçoit
des produits et donc il va piloter la
façon dont on s'en sert vous avez
quelqu'un qui s'occupe des achats et
vous avez des concepteurs de produits
qui réfléchit c'est ce qu'on va mettre
dedans
vous avez des gens qui s'occupent des
voyages professionnels vous avez des
gens qui s'occupent des implantations et
donc des déplacements domicile-travail
donc chacun de ces processus vous êtes
capable de trouver quelqu'un dans
l'entreprise à qui vous allez pouvoir
demander de vous occuper de faire de
pardon s'occuper de faire différemment
si vous avez décidé vous le patron que
ça va se passer de façon différente
il ya plein de manières de faire
différemment évidemment on va faire un
tout petit peu de brainstorming ensemble
sur le sur la question dans le cas d'une
collectivité c'est pareil il ya des
postes de regroupement dont je vais
passer rapidement
l'idée c'est toujours pareil c'est
d'être capable d'avoir quelqu'un qui va
pouvoir dire quelque chose sur la façon
dont ça se passe et éventuellement
essayer d'influer sur la façon dont ça
se passe alors je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que la première comptabilité qui
avait été mise en place au niveau des
états c'était la comptabilité des
émissions directes
maintenant il ya quelque chose qui se
développe de plus en plus qui est la
comptabilité
empreinte carbone c'est à dire que c'est
les émissions qui sont la contrepartie
de tout ce que vous allez utiliser
donc on prend tout ce que vous allez
utiliser tout ce dont vous allez
bénéficier de manière marchande ou non
marchandes par exemple en ce moment vous
êtes en train de bénéficier d'un service
de manière non marchandes
l'état paye généreusement les
enseignants chercheurs de l'école des
mines pour que vous puissiez venir en
cours gratuitement
d'accord je vous rappelle que c'est le
contribuable qui paye votre scolarité
ici essentiellement contribuer à vous
avez des frais tout petit dans
l'ensemble des frais donc c'est le
contribuable qui paye votre scolarité
par dont la moitié c'est-à-dire la
moitié votre scolarité
ac les entreprises qui payent des
contrats de recherche aux chercheurs
sauf que les contrats de recherche aux
chercheurs pays essentiellement
chercheurs ça ça paye pas vos frais de
scolarité à vous donc c'est
essentiellement voilà donc ici vous êtes
typiquement dans un contexte dans lequel
dans une vision empreinte carbone c'est
pas parce que vous payez pas que je ne
vais pas compter les émissions qui sont
la contrepartie découvre que vous
recevez d'accord donc dans cette vision
empreinte carbone on regarde les
émissions qui sont la contrepartie de la
fabrication et de la mise à disposition
de tous ceux dont vous bénéficiez alors
en france de quoi est-ce qu'on bénéficie
en bénéficient tous ou presque d'un
logement
ce logement on continue à en construire
chaque année on construit quelques
centaines de milliers de logements ce
qui veut dire que rapporter aux français
si j'étale les émissions de construction
de tous les logements en france surtout
les français et bien chaque français
émet chaque année quelques centaines de
kilos de co2 au titre de la construction
de logements alors quelques centaines de
kilos de co2 pour ne rien vous cacher
c'est les émissions qui correspondent à
1 à 2 mètres carrés de construction
béton donc vous faites un à deux mètres
carrés dans un immeuble d'appartements
en construction béton standard c'est 400
kg de co2 qui ont été émis c'est les
cimenteries des aciéries etc
après nous vivons presque tous sauf les
sdf dans un endroit qui bénéficient d'un
confort énergétique à la fois pour le
chauffage et pour les autres usages donc
ici vous avez les émissions qui sont la
contrepartie du chauffage des logements
est très marginalement de la
climatisation
là vous avez les autres usages qui sont
essentiellement des usages électriques
donc c'est la machine à laver
l'aspirateur le frigo l'ascenseur pour
ceux qui en ont un à l'éclairage etc
en france comme l'électricité est très
décarbonés et ça c'est beaucoup plus
petit que le chauffage dont je rappelle
qu'en france il est beaucoup plus fait
avec du gaz et du fioul qu'avec de
l'électricité vous avez quatre fois plus
d'énergie consommée en gaz et en fuel en
france qu en électricité pour le
chauffage
mais si j'étais en pologne et bien 7,7
ce morceau là redeviendrait aussi haut
que la barre de chauffage peut être même
un peu plus haut ensuite nous mangeons
et la mise à disposition des aliments
que nous consommons occasionne quasiment
un quart de l'empreinte carbone d'un
français est là dedans vous voyez que la
partie viande et si je rajoute les
laitages ça fait encore un bon morceau
au dessus donc le cheptel bovin
représente plus de la moitié de
l'empreinte carbone alimentaire d'un
français ensuite nous achetons donc nous
achetons des vêtements des lunettes des
chaussures des canapés des tables des
stylos des cahiers des agendas nom
s'ajoute à acheter qu'est-ce que j'ai
acheté l'autre ici ma ceinture en fait
c'est bien évidemment de l'électronique
qui aujourd'hui est un poste
significatif que vous voyez là
bref tout ce que vous trouvez dans un
supermarché et les jouets pour noël et
la balayette à toilettes tout ça il a
fallu le fabriquer et donc la
contrepartie de nos achats s'est
également quasiment un quart de
l'empreinte carbone d'un français là
dedans plus de la moitié ces des
importations donc plus de la moitié des
émissions qui n'ont pas lieu sur le sol
français et qui ont eu lieu dans tous
les pays où ont été fabriqués les
produits que nous achetons
ensuite nous nous déplaçons alors nous
nous déplaçons en voiture ça fait ce
morceau là est autrement qu'en voiture
et l'essentiel ici c'est de l'avion ici
il s'agit uniquement des déplacements
personnels les déplacements
professionnels
ils sont inclus dans l'empreinte carbone
des produits qu'on achète
dit autrement quand j'ai un chercheur
qui se déplacent en avion et bien les
émissions du déplacement en avion du
chercheur je vais les retrouver dans
l'empreinte carbone des services publics
dont vous bénéficiez d'accord c'est
comme ça que le calcul est fait c'est
pas complètement d'autres soit dit en
passant il ya l'école polytechnique
fédérale de lausanne qui vient de faire
un de publier un petit calcul montrant
qu'un professeur donc celui qui est tout
en haut de l'échelle académique à
le pfl ces six tonnes de co2 par an pour
ses déplacements en avion déplacements
professionnels donc six tonnes
c'est 60% l'empreinte carbone d'un
français qui est à 10 tonnes comme vous
pouvez lire sur ce transparent juste
pour ses déplacements professionnels
dans l'avion est déjà un post doc c'est
une tonne par an pour complètement
négligeable professeur c6 voilà donc
allait causer dans les colloques en
avion est une activité qui dans un monde
à deux degrés pas complètement sûr que
ce soit maintenu en tout cas pas au
niveau actuel et enfin nous bénéficions
tous de service alors ici vous avez les
services publics les services publics
qu'ils émettent
oui j'ai vu la question les services
publics qui émettent le plus c'est la
santé
parce que faire fonctionner l'hôpital
c'est un gros poste d'émission l'hôpital
il faut le fabriquer ce n'est pas gros
il faut le doter en instruments et en
médicaments
je vous rappelle que les spécialités
pharmaceutiques les plus chers qui sont
fabriqués par les labos pharmaceutiques
vont à l'hôpital
c'est les anticancéreux les anti jeu
pourquoi pas tout tout tout les trucs
qui vous coûte extrêmement cher et puis
il faut fabriquer plateau technique donc
le plateau technique c'est les scanners
les irm les appareils à rayons tout ce
qui permet de faire les analyses
biologiques etc
et puis il faut chauffer et puis il faut
que les infirmières les médecins les
patients viennent et les pompiers etc
et en fait quand vous regardez leur
prenne carbone du dispose de l'hôpital
ces quelques % de l'empreinte carbone du
pays 4 5 vous bénéficiez également d'un
système scolaire
il faut chauffer les bâtiments vous
bénéficiez également de d'une armée
c'est simple troisième gros poste des
services publics
l'armée américaine à elle toute seule je
crois que vous l'avez déjà dit consob le
tiers du pétrole de la france donc
qu'ils quittent presque de consolation
il ya à la navy
je les rencontre et dont je sais qu'il
existe un général deux étoiles dont le
job à plein temps
c'est d'enquiquiner les fournisseurs de
bateaux et d'avions pour qu'ils fassent
les trucs les plus économe possible
corps tellement c'est important la
consommation d'énergie donc j'ai en
france on est plus petite armée est donc
évidemment le poste est
proportionnellement moins élevés et ici
vous avez les services privés donc les
opérateurs de téléphone
et les banques le coiffeur au cinéma oui
aujourd'hui il est très très faible
aujourd'hui il est très très faible pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
en nombre de kilowattheures c'est
beaucoup plus faible et la deuxième
raison c'est que là pour le coup ça
n'est que de l'électricité alors que je
répète le chauffage chauffage et eau
chaude sanitaire en france vous avez à
peu près 100 térawattheures
d'électricité d'électricité mais vous
avez 4 100 térawattheures de pétrole et
de gaz
donc l'essentiel de la barre chauffage
c'est pas électricité c'est gaz et
pétrole oui je vous présente l'empreinte
carbone d'un français absolument et pas
d'un habitant du zimbabwe ou de mongolie
intérieure
c'est valable pour la france la question
m'a été posée sur escaut sur ce
graphique donc sur ce graphique
la climatisation est marginal si vous
allez à singapour à singapour et j'ai
entendu dire alors j'ai passé 70 % mais
à mon avis c'est un gros pack et quand
même 60 des 70 % d'électricité est
utilisé pour la clim etc d'électricité
au pétrole dont je précise c'est la
france bien avant alors maintenant on va
faire un peu flou
voilà alors je suis désolé j'ai toujours
pas changé le graphique donc là pour le
coup c'est du carbone parce que sa date
de mes jeunes années
ici vous avez le l'empreinte enfin
exactement le bilan carbone d'un
distributeur d'eau donc en l'occurrence
c'était une agence de veolia situé dans
le nord de la france alors les trois
postes que vous avez ici qui sont un peu
significatif c'est l'eau qui circule
dans un réseau c'est la mise sous
pression pour que ça circule donc il
faut de l'électricité et la production
de cette électricité engendre des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre même
en france parce que il faut beaucoup de
pompes pour faire fonctionner tout ce
machin le deuxième poste ça ça les a
beaucoup surpris c'est le renouvellement
permanent du réseau c'est-à-dire les
fournisseurs qui fabrique des compteurs
des regards des tuyaux etc
voilà ça c'est le deuxième poste et le
troisième poste significatif c'était le
génie civil pour remplacer les tuyaux
c'est que quand vous remplacer un tuyau
en général vous faites un trou le trou
est fait par un tractopelle qui
consomment du diesel et
donc c'est un poste qui est pas
complètement négligeable et vous voyez
que les déplacements de personnel s'est
pas complètement négligeable mais ça
vient loin derrière et que
l'acheminement des marchandises vient
encore plus loin derrière donc ces gens
là n'ont pas vraiment un problème de
voiture n'est pas vraiment un problème
de camions ils ont un problème de
tractopelles de pompes et d'industrie
qui les fournit vous êtes à la tête de
cette entité et moi le grand patron de
veolia je vous dis j'ai bien entendu
jancovici on va diviser les émissions de
veolia par trois
donc cher monsieur chère madame vous
avez très exactement 20 ans pour me
gagné 60% dans les émissions de ce
bastringue
qu'est ce que vous faites allez-y la
boîte à idées est ouverte
alors vous remplacez moins souvent les
tuyaux mais à ce moment vous avez des
fuites et il n'aime pas ça
mais évidemment vous avez raison il ya
quand même un sujet qui est ce qu'on est
obligé de renvoi de remplacer les tuyaux
à la même fréquence
je vous signale qu'en france il ya eu
pour partie alors pas tellement à ce
niveau là mais vous avez une grande mode
du remplacement des tuyaux en plomb par
du pvc qui n'était pas vraiment
indispensable pour des raisons
sanitaires mais qui a occasionné plein
de travaux donc oui il ya un sujet quand
même qui est de se poser cette question
là oui oui oui mais ça c'est pas votre
action à vous donc en attendant que
l'électricité cédée carbone qu'est ce
que vous faites
ouais alors il ya quelque chose qui s'en
approchent et pardon on peut faire des
tuyaux emploi effectivement oui c'est un
sujet possible absolument c'est à dire
que l'on peut demander aux fournisseurs
de tuyaux de faire des tuyaux dans les
matériaux les moins émissifs possible on
peut lui demander notamment de faire des
tuyaux en plastique recyclé parce que là
vous avez la possibilité éventuellement
d'utiliser du plastique ont cité pour ça
on peut et alors il ya un lien entre les
deux c'est qu'on peut diminuer le taux
de suite parce que si le taux de fuite
est élevé du coup vous utiliser de
l'électricité pour mettre de l'eau en
pression et tout ce que ça fait c'est
d'alimenter les fuites donc
effectivement ça ses proches de
l'efficacité des pompes
oui alors ça c'est quelque chose qui se
rapproche de jeu baisse les émissions du
génie civil est alors baisser les
émissions du génie civil un truc qui
peut se faire ces deux groupes et les
travaux vous avez par exemple des
tranchées dans lesquels on ouvre
plusieurs fois un coup pour remplacer le
tuyau puis un coup pour remplacer le
réseau électrique puis un coup pour
faire passer la fibre optique puis un
coup pour je sais pas quoi effectivement
on peut se contenter d'ouvrir une seule
fois voilà je vais pas vous faire
chercher pendant deux heures c'est juste
pour vous montrer que quand on commence
à rentrer dans le dur c'est à dire dans
un cas pratique et bien les grandes
idées sympathiques qu'on avait sur ben
oui on divise par trois donc il ya qu'à
faut qu'on quoi division par trois et
bien quand on a le bilan carbone d'une
entité sous le nez c'est là que la vraie
vie commence c'est là que la vraie vie
commence parce que c'est là qu'on
comprend où sont les arbitrages qu'on
peut et ne pas faire et quelles sont les
contreparties à chaque fois qu'on en
fait parce que si ça se trouve les
nouveaux matériaux coûtent plus cher si
ça se trouve faire bosser des ouvriers
plutôt que des tractopelles
ça va vous coûter plus cher etc etc
d'accord du soin lors du trajet alors
maintenant voici votre fournisseur
préféré c'est à dire un opérateur de
télécoms alors ici à nouveau vous avez
le bar le panorama des émissions et
alors vous voyez que c'est pas du tout
au même endroit que ça se passe
le premier poste d'un opérateur de
télécom situé en france
le premier poste c'est le les
investissements récurrents qui le fait
dans son réseau et il a besoin d'en
faire des investissements récurrents
dans son réseau parce que il faut savoir
qu'actuellement le flux de données
augmentent de quelques dizaines de pour
cent par an 80 % du flux de données sur
le réseau d'orange pour ne pas le nommer
ces de la vidéo donc l'essentiel de
votre empreinte carbone numérique c'est
du trafic vidéo dont votre plus grosse
contribution à la pollution numérique
c'est si vous êtes abonnés à netflix ou
si vous envoyez des vidéos à tire
larigot de ceci et cela
d'accord netflix youtube tout ça c'est
donc si vous regardez une vidéo regardez
là avec la plus basse définition
possible
c'est quelque chose qui très souvent ne
gêne pas considérablement le confort et
ça fait beaucoup moins de données donc
il faut qu'il maintienne alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire de maintenir son réseau
à niveau ça veut dire qu'il doit passer
commande en permanence à des gens qui
font des câbles des gens qui font des
routeurs des gens qui font etc des
supports d'antenne des antennes etc
tout ça est très matérielles après il a
un deuxième poste qui est que votre
forfait opérateur préféré arrête pas de
vous expliquer qu'au bout de deux ans
vous allez pouvoir de changer de
smartphone être nos postes etc
donc il faut fabriquer les smartphones
et donc les smartphones en question ça
rentre aussi dans son bilan carbone
puisque un opérateur télécom sans
téléphone chez les abonnés ça marche
moyen donc vous allez avoir besoin de
fabriquer et de renouveler les terminaux
ce que vous voyez c'est que la
consommation électrique de votre
téléphone est un non sujet absolu donc
en gros en france c'est quand vous
achetez le téléphone que carbonique mans
vous avez perdu une fois que vous avez
acheté du téléphone le fait que vous en
servier ou pas ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance emplois à durée de vie
donnée et le fait qu'ils consomment de
l'électricité ou pas ça n'a absolument
aucune espèce d'importance
et vous avez également l'électricité du
réseau qui compte un peu alors voilà
vous êtes embauché chez orange
qu'est ce que vous faites très bonnes
réponses
le site convaincre votre patron ne pas
passer à la 5g c'est probablement est de
très loin le premier des déterminants
que vous avez pour éviter que ça monte
et que ça commence à baisser après
mutualiser les travaux là c'est marginal
c'est la fabrication des composants du
réseau qui oui
exactement c'est à dire que au lieu de
proposer des contrats dans lequel on
renouvelle le matériel en permanence
vous essayer de proposer des contrats
dans lequel on ne renouvelle pas le
matériel en permanence et éventuellement
si on renouvelle quelque chose on essaye
de le faire avec des appareils modulaire
c'est à dire que vous commencez à avoir
des trucs dans lesquels vous pouvez
retirer un morceau est remplacé moi par
exemple dans mon smartphone j'ai demandé
autour des questions abominable aux gens
qui me regardent avec des yeux ronds
donc le seul truc de radigois machin pas
cher et où on puisse remplacer la
batterie donc germe h1 pas cher on peut
remplacer la batterie et comme la
batterie est un des premiers trucs qui
lâche en général sur les téléphones tous
les téléphones où on peut pas remplacer
la batterie avec la batterie l'âge pour
charger le téléphone
or orange ne gagne pas sa vie en faisant
le chiffre d'affaires d'apple gagne sa
vie en vous faisant voilà donc si vous
propose un téléphone dans lequel vous
avez besoin de redoubler moins souvent à
la limite on sait à peu près ce que les
arranger parce que ils peuvent vous
faire bénéficier de l'économie d'achat
de téléphone propose un truc un peu
moins cher que vous partagez entre le
client et e
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
l'essentiel alors la moitié des
émissions fabrication du téléphone c'est
l'écran et ensuite il ya encore un bon
paquet c'est l'électronique la batterie
c'est pas dominant dans le temps total
il y avait une question devra faire une
suggestion
en face il n'est pas facile il ya qu'à
faut qu'on fasse il y avait pas eu notre
max est élevé ou non là on va pas donner
la parole toujours ben oui d'une manière
générale effectivement alors c'est quoi
l'inconvénient d'avoir des téléphones
qu'ils soient récupérables recyclables
réutilisables
pardon non pas du tout il ya un
inconvénient
six voiliers
non non
alors le chiffre d'affaires de ce qu'ils
produisent mais vous êtes en orange vous
en foutez donc moi je suis orange
chiffre d'affaires d'apple ça
m'intéresse pas je m'en fous
complètement du chiffre d'affaires
d'apple
oui
j'ai parlé pas entendu
ou alors je pensais pas exactement ça
mais oui non en fait l'inconvénient
principal si vous avez des objets qui
durent plus longtemps c'est que
l'innovation technique pénètre moins
vite c'est juste ça donc en gros ça
suppose que vous tenez un discours sur
la nouveauté qui devient totalement
différent et donc ça vous disrupt
totalement votre discours marketing
donc en gros toute l'équipe comme et
marketing et à changer enfin ou plus
exactement tous leurs discours et a
changé
voilà alors maintenant c'est une société
qui fait du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
leur premier poste c'est la fabrication
de l'acier et du ciment
alors là c'est hors utilisation des
bâtiments derrière et des
infrastructures
ici vous avez la consommation des engins
de chantier les postes d'enrobé c'est
pour fabriquer ce qui va sur les sur les
routes là et vous voyez la logistique
alors c'est toujours pareil qu'est ce
que vous faites oui c'est une option
vous pouvez effectivement augmenté la
construction bois oui la limite
exactement dont vous avez un calcul du
pouce que vous faites sur la
productivité des forêts françaises et
vous regarder jusqu'où vous pouvez
monter en volume d'approvisionnement et
donc combien de logements ça vous permet
de faire
et alors j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
vous ça ne permet pas de faire 300 mille
logements par an ça veut pas dire qu'il
faudrait le faire parce que c'est en
train de dire et ça veut pas dire qu'on
va pouvoir faire éternellement 300
milles devant par an mais ça veut juste
dire que remplacer tous les logements
qu'on fait aujourd'hui en acier béton
par des logements en bois 1 pour 1 à 300
milles de logements par an
malheureusement ça ça passe pas mais
vous avez la bonne réponse sur la
manière de comprendre où est la limite
oui oui absolument on peut mettre moins
de ciment par mètre cube de béton
j'ai demandé à une entreprise de
construction aujourd'hui que vous
fassiez le béton pour le première étage
pour le quatrième on met la même
quantité de ciment par mètre cube de
béton
or vraisemblablement que les efforts de
structures sont pas les mêmes au rez de
chaussée que au quatrième donc on peut
probablement en modules et ça de façon
un peu astucieuse oui une suggestion
alors vous achetez votre assise aux
islandais sauf que l'acier primaire est
en fait en réduisant du minerai de fer
avec du coq ça même si c'est des
islandais qui s'en chargent savait mais
toujours autant mais vous avez
effectivement une partie de la réponse
vous pouvez recycler plus l'acier et
donc quand vous des construisez un
bâtiment vous récupérez les ferrailles
que voulait et c'est donc ça
effectivement on peut faire ce genre de
chose au dessus de gestion oui
absolument
sauf que vous allez avoir un ça va vous
coûter beaucoup plus cher mais
effectivement c'est une option
la dernière option est en fait que sont
en train de faire une partie des
entreprises du secteur
c'est que vous basculez de la
construction vers l' usage c'est à dire
que plutôt que de construire des
bâtiments et des autoroutes et bien vous
vous emparez entre guillemets des
bâtiments et des autoroutes existantes
et vous gérez lusage qui est évidemment
moins émissifs que la construction dans
un certain nombre de cas de figure pas
dans toussaint en ce qui concerne les
autoroutes il faut quand même faire
balancer des voitures dessus voilà
maintenant une banque alors une banque
c'est hors engagements c'est-à-dire hors
émissions des clients là vous avez les
émissions de fonctionnement des
bâtiments ici vous avez les déplacements
et ici vous avez les achats de services
est enfin là vous avez la fabrication de
l'haïti sur pareille qu'est ce qu'on
fait
chaque année en ce moment en france pour
gagner 1 euros de produit net bancaire
donc un euro de chiffre d'affaires en
gros une banque doit faire circuler 30%
de données en plus tous les ans qu'est
ce qu'on fait
alors vous pouvez changer la chaudière
absolument et isolées j'ai envie de dire
ça c'est la partie la plus simple
oui oui c'est tout ça c'est le confort
thermique des bâtiments
ok on peut faire des choses
pire que si vous aviez les agences parce
que le numérique par euros de valeur
ajoutée c'est bien pire que d'avoir des
gens dans des violences est par ailleurs
vous fait quoi des gens qui étaient dans
les agences
alors cette question va se poser souvent
c'est à dire que si la seule solution
c'est de contracter l'activité qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des gens qui travaillent et
s'est du reste une des raisons pour
lesquelles il ya plein de gens qui ont
envie de s'attaquer à ce problème
pardon alors y avait là oui oui
absolument
dans le favoriser le télétravail à temps
partiel peut avoir un avantage à deux
conditions
la première c'est que ce soit
essentiellement du télétravail à
domicile parce qu'à ce moment vous
n'avez pas besoin de construire de
surface supplémentaire et le déficit de
l'hiver reste un peu chauffé même s'il
est moins chauffer dans la journée que
le soir et donc vous avez une
valorisation du chauffage que vous
faites de toute façon la deuxième
condition c'est que vous en profitiez
pas quand vous êtes chez vous pour
prendre la voiture pour aller changer
d'air alors oubliez prises pour aller au
travail
mais comme on est des animaux et qu'on
aime bien sortir de la grotte il ya
beaucoup de gens qui font ça la
troisième condition c'est que l'espace
que vous n'occupez plus au bureau soit
affecté à quelqu'un d'autre dit
autrement qu'il n'y ait que des bureaux
dans affectés là où vous travaillez et
qu'il y en ait moins que l'effectif
total
sinon si votre bureau est vide et
chauffer quand même vous avez rien gagné
voilà donc il faut donc sous certaines
conditions c'est quelque chose qui peut
marcher oui il y avait une suggestion la
vache et plus non bon oui
oui à l'époque où le houleux alors
aujourd'hui ça n'a malheureusement plus
dense mais à l'époque où l'énergie
étaient rares et chers effectivement les
grandes activités productives avait
tendance à loger les gens qu'il aurait
été nécessaire juste à côté c'est comme
ça qu'on a fait les cons billets que
vous avez les cités ouvrières d'un
certain nombre d'usinés tu sais oui
c'était une façon de la roue de baisser
la quantité d'énergie utilisée par les
gens allaient dernière suggestion elle
dit alors réduire le nombre de bureaux
individuels dans un immeuble ça ne
change pas grand chose par rapport à
avoir un open space
si chacun à sa place qui est non
affectés enfin qui est non utilisé s'il
n'est pas là en fait ce qui compte c'est
les mètres carrés de surface au sol que
vous allez utiliser ou pas bon ça
c'était juste pour rire pour dire que
même l'alliance française ou son
équivalent possède aussi un inventaire
des missions alors une fois que je vous
ai dit tout ça je vais avancer un peu
parce que
le
l'heure tourne
je vais aller non je m'aime pas vous
dire ça parce que j'ai
je vais directement à 100 quand on se
donne un objectif de réduction des
émissions il ya quelque chose qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que ce qui est
important pour l'atmosphère c'est les
objectifs en valeur absolue ce que
demande entre guillemets le système
climatique pour limiter le réchauffement
à l'avenir c'est la limitation des
émissions globales de l'humanité
d'accord c'est pas la limitation des
émissions par personne ou par voitures
ont passé la limitation globale ce qui
veut dire que quand vous êtes une
entreprise
la bonne question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que je vais chercher à limiter
mes émissions par cafetière vendus ou
les émissions de l'ensemble de
l'entreprise est alors je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui la réponse qui est fait
par à peu près toutes les entreprises
que je connais jusqu'à récemment
maintenant ça commence un peu à changer
mais jusqu'à récemment c'était je limite
les émissions par cafetière vendus ah
oui mais comment évolue le nombre de
cafetière que vous allez vendre
ah bah ça j'espère que ça augmente et
quand vous faites les intérêts composés
évidemment vous tomber sur quelque chose
qui n'est pas du tout dans les ordres de
grandeur qui sont nécessaires pour
arriver à sa contribution sa part à
l'effort dans un dans un monde qui doit
se décarbonés globalement vous voyez que
en ce qui concerne l'économie dans son
ensemble depuis contient les
statistiques qui sont là les émissions
par objets fabriqués ou par services
rendus n'arrête pas de baisser alors que
les émissions globales n'arrête pas
d'augmenter
donc si on veut faire baisser les
émissions globales ça veut dire que
l'objectif est sûre les émissions
globales
donc si vous êtes une entreprise
sérieuse et que vous dites je veux
sérieusement contribué à la
décarbonation vous n'allez pas prendre
un objectif relatif tout en disant mon
chiffre d'affaires va continuer à croire
après mes résultats aussi peuvent que
c'est ce que les actionnaires demandent
vous allez prendre un objectif de
réduction globale est exactement comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure sur la 5g
quelque part si c'est vraiment ça votre
objectif c'est quoi qu'il en coûte
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre de cas de figure dans lequel les
entreprises ne le ferons jamais
spontanément parce que ça a conduit à
contracter leurs activités et donc là je
viens de vous dire quelque chose
absolument évident qui est que si c'est
pas la puissance publique qui se charge
de mettre l'objectif est de dire vous
allez respecter quoi qu'il en coûte
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui ne le
feront pas vous allez dire à mes à ce
moment un certain nombre d'entreprises
vont péricliter et je vais vous dire oui
absolument
c'est tout à fait exact donc choisissez
les bonnes mais il ya d'autres objectifs
collectifs pour lesquels c'est déjà le
cas et il y en a deux en particulier qui
sans fin où il y en a un plus exactement
qui est que si une entreprise
aujourd'hui n'est pas capable de payer
ses charges et ses impôts donc par
exemple sa tva ou ses charges sociales
l'entreprise fait faillite
donc aujourd'hui on considère que au nom
de la solidarité qu'on doit avec le
reste du pays soient fiscales soit
sociale c'est à dire que mon entreprise
paye des charges pour que on assure
gratuitement des soins des gens malades
ou la retraite à des gens qui ne
travaillent plus encore où la
contribution au cours à l'école des
mines
ça c'est la tva est bien à travers ses
contributions
mon entreprise contribuer à la
solidarité nationale je conçois très
bien je discute absolument pas et si on
ne devient plus capable dans mon
entreprise de payer ses charges là on
passe à la barre du tribunal de commerce
et on dépose le bilan
donc il ya déjà un cas de figure dans
lequel on considère que c'est pas
anormal qu'une entreprise high au tapis
parce qu'elle est pas raccord avec des
objectifs nationaux et donc c'est
absolument évident que si on donne des
objectifs en valeur absolue aux
entreprises sur leurs émissions il y en
a qui ont au tapis c'est absolument
évident mais choisis ton camp camarade
bongo bien on considère que les
canicules à 50 degrés dans trente ans on
n'en veut pas et à ce moment on fait ce
qu'on doit faire
ou bien on considère que les entreprises
doivent pouvoir entreprendre
aujourd'hui il sent qu on les emmerde et
à ce moment on finira par avoir les
canicules à 52 et voilà il faut savoir
ce qu'on veut
bon ça je passe parce que j'ai plus le
temps alors tout ce que je vous ai
raconté pendant ces
et court dans une entreprise comment
est-ce que ça peut se présenter
maintenant si je fais un tableau un peu
large comme vous avez pu le comprendre
les chaînes de valeur des entreprises
dépendent de l'approvisionnement
énergétique puisque l'énergie c'est la
transformation et la transformation
c'est tout le système économique
mais cette énergie est essentiellement
fossiles et de temps en temps elle a un
petit chaos sur le volume dont on peut
disposer alors quand il ya un petit
cadeau ou un gros caillou sur le volume
dont on peut disposer la première chose
qui se passe à court terme c'est que
vous allez avoir un choc de prix et ça
ça va se répercuter dans les achats
d'une entreprise donc une premier truc
qui va se passer quand vous avez un choc
pétrolier c'est que vous avez un peu
d'inflation qui arrivent dans les
charges d'une entreprise mais il ya un
deuxième effet qui peut être beaucoup
plus important dans certaines
entreprises
c'est que à peu près tout ce qui
s'achète sur un marché est asservi aux
prix du pétrole
dit autrement quand vous regardez le
prix des céréales dans le monde le prix
de la poudre de lait dans le monde le
prix du nickel dans le monde le prix de
l'or dans le monde le prix de n'importe
quoi qui s'achète
eh bien ces prix là pour des raisons
d'allocation d'actifs sur les marchés
financiers sont asservis au prix du
pétrole
on l'a constaté une année en travaillant
chez danone parce qu'il y avait une
forte hausse du prix du lait alors qu'il
y avait une forte hausse du prix du
pétrole et ce n'était pas du tout un
effet inflationniste n'était pas du tout
parce que les tracteurs coûter plus cher
pour avancer rien à voir avec ça donc
vous avez un deuxième effet kiss cool
qui vous arrive à ce moment là c'est que
tout ce qu'achète l'entreprise augmente
également dès lors qu'il s'agit de
matières premières et donc ça c'est un
deuxième impact sur les charges mais
surtout la contraction de
l'approvisionnement énergétique en
volume va vous engendrez une répression
c'est ce que je vous ai montré au
premier cours et ça ça va vous impact et
vos ventes
donc si vous avez une tension sur
l'énergie vous avez déjà le problème qui
arrive deux côtés à la fois à la fois
sur les charges et sur le chiffre
d'affaires ensuite vous avez les effets
du changement climatique qui sont déjà à
l'oeuvre
donc là par exemple en ce moment il ya
un certain nombre de chantiers qui vont
devoir fermer parce qu'il fait trop
chaud pour laisser les ouvriers dehors
et c'est normal et à ce moment vous avez
un impact sur l'activité core donc les
marchands d'eau glacée et de glace
31 par contre il ya tout un tas d'autres
gens qui se frotte pas du tout les mains
la sncf va accumuler les retards parce
que dès qu'il ya un train pas climatisé
quelque part il ya un malaise qu'il va y
avoir un voyageur qui va faire un
malaise etc
donc vous avez tout a pas de gens qui
vont se voit là vous avez dans dans un
autre référé un truc un peu rigolo comme
les débits d'étiage des ponts des
fleuves pardon sont en train de baisser
c'est une personne de chez vinci qui m'a
raconté sa l'autre jour vous avez un
certain nombre de ponts anciens vous
savez genre les ponts en pierre que vous
avez au dessus des fleuves les piles de
ponts je sais pas si vous êtes jamais
demandé sur quoi reposait alors pas des
pieux mais les platier c'est à dire des
troncs qui sont posés à plat et qui
servent dans base pour qu'on puisse
poser dessus une colonne en pierre qui a
une embase beaucoup plus petit qui sinon
s'enfoncerait dans le lit de la rivière
et c'est c'est trop ils sont sous le
niveau d'étiage c'est à dire qu'ils sont
immergés en permanence au moment où on
construit le pont ont fait en sorte
qu'ils soient recouverts d'eau en
permanence pour pas qu'ils pourrissent
parce que le bois quand il est immergé
en permanence il pourrit pas et avec le
réchauffement climatique
vous avez des rivières dans le débit
d'étiage commence à devenir tellement
bas que les troncs en question se
découvre périodiquement
donc il se met à courir et le pont plat
d'aba où vous avez un pont qui s'est
déjà cassé la gueule comme ça en france
ça c'est un effet du réchauffement
climatique si vous êtes l'entreprise
située juste à côté et que vous avez
votre entrepôt juste derrière le pont et
bien vous allez faire un peu la gueule
parce que vous allez avoir des problèmes
pour livrer vos clients donc ces effets
du changement climatique ils vont
croissant si vous avez lu usine arkema à
houston vous faites un peu la gueule
quand après passe et cetera et cetera
donc ce genre de truc ça augmente ça
n'arrête pas d'augmenter et ça va avoir
des effets sur l'entreprise
après vous pouvez avoir un certain
nombre de parties prenantes de
l'entreprise qui demande qu'on s'y
prenne autrement donc vous pouvez voir
les clients qui disent moi je veux qu'on
fasse autrement donc par exemple les
clients en suède dit je veux moi prendre
l'avion et à ce moment si vous faites
des avions ou vendée - vous pouvez avoir
la puissance publique qui dit je
voudrais qu'on s'y prenne autrement et à
ce moment où fait d'énormes des taxes
des quotas etc
alors je prends un exemple
volontairement caricatural mais
intéressant anne hidalgo dit demain
matin il n'y a plus un véhicule avec la
propulsion thermique qui rentre dans
paris à ce moment si vous vendez des
véhicules à propulsion thermique aux
franciliens
un peu mal ensuite vous pouvez avoir les
gens du monde financier qui disent nous
on va commencer à regarder sérieusement
ce qui se passe du récit sont en train
de le faire en ce moment
dites moi ce que vous faites et si ce
que vous faites à une tête qui me plaît
pas je vais arrêter de vous prêter de
l'argent
alors ça pour le moment c'est un risque
faible il ya trop d'argent en
circulation mais enfin il ya quand même
quelque chose de cette nature qui est en
train de prendre place ensuite il peut y
avoir un sujet rh
c'est à dire que vous avez ou pas des
gens qui sont formés à comprendre d'où
vient le problème et à s'en occuper
si ces gens là sont présents dans
l'entreprise quand l'entreprise a un
problème on peut éventuellement faire
une attribution correcte des causes si
ces gens là ne sont pas dans
l'entreprise au moment où le problème
arrive
l'attribution des causes n'est pas fait
et donc on ne le traite pas et donc ils
empirent et enfin vous avez dans cette
histoire des ong dans le métier c'est de
secouer le cocotier dans tous les sens
quoi qu'il en tombe voilà donc voila
tout petit résumé de ce que vous avez
dans l'entreprise et le carbone est ce
que vous allez trouver dans votre vie
future
alors dans votre vie future qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir avoir un certain nombre
d'entre vous se diront une fois que j'ai
entendu tout ça si j'ai envie de
m'occuper un peu du problème le plus
évident ce sera aller m'occuper de
l'efficacité énergétique donc je vais
faire des cafetières plus efficace voilà
donc là dedans vous allez vous occuper
en gros de ce qui fait plaisir à tout le
monde
on va avoir autant de tout sauf que ça
sera mieux fabriquer mieux pensée etc
il ya des gens qui vont également
s'occuper du contenu carbone de
l'énergie donc c'est des gens qui vont
faire des renouvelables du nucléaire ou
éventuellement de la capture et
séquestration
et puis on peut aussi avoir des gens qui
se disent ah tiens je vais quand même
occupé d'aller regarder ce qui se passe
dans les indicateurs qu'on utilise ou
quelque chose à mon avis beaucoup plus
intéressant
comment est-ce qu'on gère au mieux le
système si cet indicateur se met à faire
la gueule parce que si cet indicateur
pour des raisons d'approvisionnement
abonde se met à faire la gueule de toute
façon la question c'est quoi la
meilleure organisation qu'on est dans ce
contexte
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas un
économiste en france qui se posent la
question de ckoi la moins mauvaise
manière de s'organiser si le pib se
contracte de manière structurelle
or ça aurait beaucoup de valeur parce
qu'aujourd'hui
y'a pas de d'offres il n'y a rien sur le
marché qui vous dit si ça doit se
contracter de façon structurelle c'est
quoi la meilleure manière de s'organiser
et il faut pas oublier ces gens là donc
tous les gens qui s'occupent de limiter
la croissance démographique sont aussi
des gens qui font oeuvre utile sur une
planète qui reste désespérément limitée
à près de 1000 km de diamètre
après vous avez évidemment tous les gens
qui s'occupent de mesurer alors ces gens
là ne sont pas dans l'action pour mon
entreprise quand elle mesure n est pas
dans l'action par contre aller dans la
préparation de l'action parce que si
vous n'êtes pas capables de faire la
différence entre un dix cents et mille
la probabilité pour que de vous même
vous à lou ye les moyens là où ils sont
efficaces et à peu près nulles et j'ai
un milliard d'exemple en tête
voilà alors après il ya une autre
catégorie malheureusement assez
développés qui consiste à dire le
problème est déjà traités d'accord je
m'appelle volkswagen je vend toujours
autant de voitures à pétrole devant
quelques chars électriques en allemagne
et en pologne et je dis regardez je
m'occupe du problème j'ai entendu ça pas
plus tard qu'hier soir donc ce que vous
en parler autre exemple un chef
d'entreprise qui avant vendait des
disjoncteurs maintenant on vend surtout
des équipements datacenter et pour le
numérique sachant que le numérique son
empreinte carbone augmente de 10 % par
an y'a rien de moins durable sur la
planète et il dit oui ou non fait de
l'efficacité donc le problème est traité
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose
également qui est un vrai débouché pour
un certain nombre de gens qui consiste à
dire où tout ça va bien il n'y a aucun
problème dans les services comme à
l'heure où ça va peut vous concerner
mais ça vous en avez également pléthore
dans les services comme service comme
est payé pour dire problème là est sous
contrôle
bon ça je voulais déjà dit et enfin il
reste également des gens qui vont aller
travailler pour limiter la déforestation
donc c'est aussi le planning familial
mais gérer correctement les forêts donc
gérer correctement les forêts avec des
essences qui vont résister aux
changements climatiques etc
c'est quelque chose qui est utile vous
avez également les gens qui vont
s'occuper des des régimes alimentaires
c'est également quelque chose qui est
utile et enfin vous avez quelque chose
que je ne rajoute pas dans ce graphique
qui est tous les gens qui vont s'occuper
des impacts du changement climatique
pour essayer de développer ce qu'on
appelle l' adaptation puisque comme vous
l'expliqué encore une partie des coûts
sont partis et qui va bien falloir faire
avec
voilà dans tout ça il va falloir et je
pense que c'est peut-être une des
parties les plus utiles de cours ce que
je vais vous dire maintenant vous aurez
toujours partout et tout le temps
puisque c'est les euros qui reste
l'indicateur majeur de ce qu'on utilise
dans le monde de l'entreprise ou le
monde de la fonction publique
une action ira toujours en face de
quelqu'un qui accepte de payer pour
donc il y aura toujours besoin pour
déclencher l'action de convaincre les
gens qui ont les mains sur le cordon de
la bourse
toujours vous aurez toujours besoin de
savoir expliquer ce que vous avez en
tête expliqué simplement quelque chose à
des gens qui par ailleurs ne savent pas
ce que vous savez c'est compliqué parce
que vous si vous avez bien écoutez vous
savez maintenant considérablement plus
de choses que la population française
considérablement plus de choses que
l'élu français considérablement plus de
choses que le fonctionnaire français
d'accord et vous aurez toujours le
problème d'essayer d'expliquer en peu de
temps et peu de mots à des gens qui au
plus seront bourré d'idées reçues
parce qu'ils ont confondu la vérité avec
ce qu'il ya dans le journal d'où l'on
part quel est le problème
et qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et je vous
assure que ça sera souvent une vraie
difficulté un problème sans la solution
on n'intéresse absolument personne donc
à chaque fois que moi je reçois plein de
messages de gens qui me disent qu'est-ce
que je peux faire et c'est en fait le le
camp vous allez essayer d'agir pour ceux
d'entre vous qui essaieront d'agir il
faut toujours identifié le problème et
essayer de commencer à construire la
solution en même temps je peux vous dire
que dans le monde politique un problème
sans solution vous n'avez que porte
close
ça m'intéresse absolument personne je
vais vous expliquer le problème sans
fondement quand vous n'avez pas votre
solution derrière et si vous avez une
solution qui ne correspond à aucun
problème vous avez beaucoup plus
facilement la porte ouverte elle en
général c'est comme ça que ça marche
aujourd'hui
donc il faut absolument que vous ayez la
solution avec le problème et en
entreprise c'est pareil si vous allez
enquiquiner votre patron en disant on
devrait faire un truc si vous n'avez pas
là que d'une sur la façon de vous
attaquer aux problèmes que vous avez
identifié
vous aurez beaucoup de mal à vous faire
entendre il ya quelque chose également
qui est important c'est que quand on
s'attaque à un problème nouveau on doit
chasser quelque chose de prêts existants
donc on est dans la négociation et
lutter s'occuper de ce problème
ça n'est que une négociation permanente
qu'une négociation permanente
bien évidemment il faut savoir
comprendre ce qui se passe est donc
observer il faut comprendre les ressorts
de la psychologie des gens vous avez en
face de vous donc si vous savez pas leur
faire l'article vous irez nulle part et
enfin dernier point est un type vraiment
n'ayez jamais jamais peur de poser une
question jamais vous pouvez pas savoir
le nombre de conneries qu'on peut faire
en entreprise
parce que quelqu'un dans une réunion
s'est dit je serai ridicule si je pose
est si je posais la question là sur un
truc que j'ai pas compris et derrière sa
part dans le décor voilà donc vraiment
je vous assure le ridicule ne tue pas et
en plus vous êtes des gens intelligents
donc ce question vous allez poser
normalement sport complètement stupide
n'ayez jamais peur de poser une question
faut pas être agressif mais déjà peur de
poser une question voilà et donc moi je
vous reverrai plus beaux examen et bonne
suite
[Applaudissements]